monsieur ministre mesdames et messieurs
des députés la science est ouverte
je vous rappelle que l'ordre du jour
appelle la suite du projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite que ce matin l'assemblée a
poursuivi l'examen des articles
s'arrêtant à l'amendement 16 669 à
l'article 8
nous en revenons donc à cet amendement
sur verhote vous faites un amendement un
rappel au règlement pour permettre à
madame taurine de tout à fait rendre
mais merci 10dans pouvant propose votre
enthousiasme d'abord après le repas ça
n'est jamais facile
je voudrais simplement ce pour
l'organisation de nos travaux que vous
puissiez nous confirmer qu'au rythme de
la dernière heure de ce matin nous
pourrions finir dans les 280 7 jours
prochains c'est à dire que nous
pourrions éventuellement en passant huit
mois avec la fermeture de l'hémicycle
terminé dans l'année qui vient est
encore tout juste j'ai calculé ça paraît
difficile est ce que vous pourriez nous
confirmer l'organisation de de nos
travaux et la longueur qu'il pourrait
prendre à au rythme où nous allons merci
monsieur rivero
chacun aura vu compris que le
l'intervention de feu monsieur ries
brottes ne s'inscrive dans aucunement
dans notre procédure procédure de rappel
au règlement donc je n'en tiens pas qu'à
madame taurine
mentoring vous avez et vous seul la
parole sur l'amendement 16 669 oui
simplement pour vous dire que donc comme
nous avions demandé la suppression de
cet article nous allons demander la
suppression de cet alinéa je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur sans plus
d'argument défaveur monsieur le ministre
défavorable il y avait un scrutin public
sur cet amendement il est annoncé dans
l'hémicycle et avec l'autorisation de la
taurine vous accepter qu'on puisse
procéder au vote dorine ya pas les 5
minutes mais on vient d'arriver c'est
pour ça que je vous sollicite
bon allez on va attendre cinq minutes
dans le cinq minutes effectivement
ouais non mais on pouvait si l'auteur de
l'amendement nous le demande nous le lui
autorise on pouvait le faire on va
attendre un instant
mignola ne vous en privez pas mais elles
peuvent ils à monsieur le président je
voudrais certain que l'assemblée
nationale met à profit chaque minute
pour travailler dans le sens de
l'intérêt général et donc au titre de
l'article sont j'avais formulée il ya
désormais 36 heures une demande qui
était la répartition pourcentage des
temps de parole par groupe parlementaire
et je me permets de réitérer cette
demande si les services de l'assemblée
peuvent nous donner cette information ou
le président de l'assemblée nationale où
le ministre en charge des relations avec
le parlement n'est pas donner suite à
votre demande si elle avait été exprimé
auparavant
je ne manquerai pas monsieur le
président lors de la conférence des
présidents de leur dire combien vous
êtes attaché à pouvoir disposer de ce
document je m'adresse à la fonction ou
est pas la personne jeu des yeux ne
trouvera tout le respect que je te jeter
votre personne je profite de votre
intervention pour gagner quelques
secondes puisque nous avons cinq minutes
l'un les uns et les autres à rester
peut-être que le monsieur matelly
souhaite aussi à s'exprimer
non alors monsieur peu
une censure non je voulais je voulais
aller dans le sens de la proposition de
monsieur mignola si je peux me permettre
d'en dans la mesure où ce cette espèce
de tableaux permettrait entre autres
d'avoir une évaluation du degré de
travail des différents groupes d'accord
[Musique]
voilà
mais mes chers collègues vous avez pu
vous exprimer une façon utile et
précieuses sur l'organisation de nos
travaux j'en remercie et monsieur peu et
le président mignola je vous propose que
maintenant nous puissions passer au vote
sur l'amendement qui a été défendu par
madame taurine et sur lequel il y à une
demande de scrutin public chacun a pu
regagner sa place
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat 46 votants le 45 exprimé
majorité 23 pour 4 contre 41 il est
rejeté et le 1006 le cese 1840 madame
taurine défend donc cet amendement
demande la suppression de l'alinéa 2
sans merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
donc je précise que l'alinéa 2 définit
que le montant de la retraite serait
égal au nombre de points fois la valeur
du point
inscrite sur le nombre de points
inscrits sur le compte personnel fois la
valeur de service du point voix c'est la
définition même de la lisibilité du
système et de la facilité la
compréhension du système donc des
savoirs
merci monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président où il supprimer
cet alinéa 2 rend incompréhensible
inintelligible cet article avis
défavorable merci je mets aux voix
l'amendement présenté par madame taurine
avis défavorable de monsieur le
rapporteur et de monsieur le ministre
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté le 25 1016 madame taurine
donc identique en nous demandant la
suppression de cette ligne à jour merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président il s'agit d'une suppression
d'une partie de la linea qui notamment
porto sur la fin précisions concernant
la valeur de service du point fixe et à
sa date des faits et donc encore une
fois
supprimer cette partie de la linea de
rendre inintelligible incompréhensible
c'est alinéa dans son entier avis
défavorable merci sur cet amendement
avis défavorable de monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejeté un amendement donnant lieu
à des discussions communes le 26 1821
monsieur brunel oui nous proposons deux
par rapport à cet alinéa de rédiger une
nouvelle formule notamment 7 calculée en
annuités sur la base des 25 meilleures
années de salaire et des six derniers
mois de traitement hors primes
en effet chacun sait que ne pas
augmenter la part dévolue retraite alors
que la part des 65 ans et plus devrait
augmenter de plus de 40% d'ici 2070
revient donc à une baisse équivalente de
des pensions
on le sait où on ignore mais pas non
plus pour ceux qui en ont les moyens
qu'ils tenteront inévitablement de
combler ses pertes par la capitalisation
ce qui implique c'est la satisfaction de
différentes compagnies d'assurance et
notamment blackrock et leur consorts
chacun sait également que notre système
par points est l'outil idéal pour un
gouvernement souhaitant baisser les
pensions
c'est ce qui s'est passé en suède vous
pouvez pas le nier avec votre projet de
loi nul besoin de réformes et de risquer
la grande social avec une petite
modification de la valeur de service du
point et le tour est joué
donc c'est dans ce cadre là que nous
souhaitons garder nous cette formule
d'annuités sur la base des 25 meilleures
années et des six derniers mois
merci monsieur le député amendements
identiques dans cette décision commune
ledit 1341 madame madame de l'os ou
monsieur minot défendu le dit 1984 me
semble pas défendu et toujours dans
cette discussion commune le 5593 oui
monsieur me noyer est signataire
merci monsieur le président c'est un peu
l'amendement que j'ai dont j'ai parlé
lors de ma prise de parole pour
l'article et 8 puisque dans le système
actuel le montant des pensions de
retraite est calculé sur les 25
meilleures années de cotisations pour le
secteur privé et les six derniers mois
pour la fonction publique
or ce projet de loi propose quant à lui
de mettre en place un système de calcul
de la pension qui prend en compte
l'intégralité de la carrière
donc ça va considérablement baisser les
pensions des retraites de la majorité
des français dont la mesure dans la
mesure où les mauvaises années seront
également elles prises en compte
de plus cela va défavorisés les
personnes qui ont vu leur rémunération
progresser pendant leur carrière car
elle et qu'elle avait occupé des
fonctions à plus fortes responsabilités
et le mérite qu'elles auront acquis ne
sera donc plus valorisées dans le cadre
de leur retraite comme c'est le cas
actuellement donc nous vous proposons
cet amendement qui a pour but de
préserver cette disposition qui
et dans le système actuel merci monsieur
minot maintenant monsieur le rapporteur
oui parce que excusez moi l'autre
amendement j'aurais dû le dire le dr
1974 n'est pas défendu merci monsieur le
président le but de cet amendement est
de calculer la retraite en annuités sur
la base des 25 meilleures années ou des
six derniers mois donc vous rétablissez
par cet amendement à des paramètres les
plus anciens distributive du système
actuel en effet dans le système actuel
les bas salaires et les salariés
notamment aux fins de carrières les plus
compliqués ne bénéficie pas de la règle
retenue en matière de salaire de
référence avec l'acquisition de points
sur l'ensemble de la carrière
nous revenons fondements de notre
système par retraite qui nous permet
d'avoir une autre est la plus
représentative possible de la carrière
de l'assuré sens et ferro distribuant
tyro distributif ni avantages réservés
aux seuls carrière ascendante donc
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président on repart sur une discussion
de fond mais je vois je veux pas
l'éluder ce sujet a été abordé
nombreuses reprises le système actuel en
force et inégalités il les renforce nous
l'avons déjà dit nous l'avons démontré
pourquoi parce que en réalité ce ne sont
que les dispositifs de solidarité qui
permettent d'atténuer les écarts qui
sont amplifiées par le système actuel
par annuités et qui du coup obligé un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes à
devoir travailler jusqu'à 67 ans pour
annuler avec la décote qui concentre
l'essentiel des droits familiaux sur les
familles de trois enfants
non on sait que la plupart
bénéficier essentiellement opère
notamment dans cette majoration
on a bien un système qui sans doute a
été construit à une période où cela
avait du sens où les carrières étaient
majoritairement ascendante dans une
france où je ne parle pas de l'immédiate
après guerre mais en plus tôt des trente
glorieuses où la dynamique économique
était celle du plein emploi ou la vie
professionnelle se faisait dans une
seule entreprise souvent du début à la
fin la carrière cela ce n'est plus la
réalité du 21e siècle
il vient d'ailleurs celle de la fin du
xxème et pour autant il nous faut
préserver cette solidarité nous faut
préserver cette répartition
il nous faut préserver ce vivre ensemble
que nous avons construit au travers de
ce système de retraites c'est pourquoi
nous proposons nous d'avancer vers un
système par répartition toujours et par
point avec cette notion d'âge déquilibre
qui permet d'assurer à notre système à
sa solidarité
une durabilité réel et qui renforce la
confiance des plus jeunes générations
vers leurs aînés dont rappelons le le
système par répartition amène les plus
jeunes à payer par leurs cotisations
les pensions des plus âgés donc oui nous
confirmons que il est plus intéressant
d'avoir notamment pour les carrières qui
sont plaque peu évolutive pour les
carrières heurtées pour tous ceux qui
n'auront pas un parcours linéaire il est
plus intéressant d'avoir un calcul sur
l'ensemble de la carrière tout en
maintenant les éléments de solidarité
qui je sais vous sont chers à vous aussi
d'ailleurs
les éléments de solidarité qui sont
constitutifs de notre capacité à vivre
ensemble à vider pas voir monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre
alors je vais maintenant mettre aux voix
chez à huy par l'aris climat sur la
malène dallas avait demandé la parole
puis monsieur petit merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous
pouvez pas dire qu'aujourd'hui le
système actuel est injuste par rapport
au carré à orthez c'est faux parce qu'il
ya quand même il ya déjà un mécanisme de
solidarité
alors peut-être qu'il n'est pas
suffisant peut-être qu'il fallait
effectivement et on va se rejoindre
améliorer le dispositif de sécurité de
solidarité sur les carrières heurtées
mais enfin où est-ce que vous avez
imaginé qu'une carrière était totalement
linéaire
parce que c'est seulement dans ce cas là
c'est seulement dans le cas d'une
carrière total d'une vie professionnelle
linéaire que votre passage à la totalité
de la durée de cotisation pourrait être
intéressant parce que la réalité c'est
que votre dispositif de solidarité
il est plus fort pour toutes les
carrières heurtées oui ça c'est clair
mais pour toutes les autres derrière les
carrière ascendante et fort c'est quand
même d'admettre que sur une vie
professionnelle il ya une évolution
qu'elle soit salariale c'est la base sur
est pas rémunéré
au bout de vingt ans d'ancienneté comme
vous l'êtes ci encore des durée
d'ancienneté long comme vous l'êtes en
début de carrière
et puis qui plus est aujourd'hui en
fonction de la maîtrise de l'expérience
des métiers du savoir faire vous avez
des progressions à l'intérieur des
entreprises ou carrément des changements
d orientation professionnelle différente
donc pour tout cela votre système
ça sera perdant parce que la réalité
c'est que le fait de prendre en compte
la totalité va faire que il y aura
forcément des perdants et c'est cela que
nous contestons par le biais de ces
amendements merci monsieur petit oui je
voudrais juste rappeler qu on a eu la
comparaison dans la défense de
l'amendement avec les années 70 en
disant qu'on serait 40 % de retraités en
plus je rappelle que le montant le
montant des retraites a dit swiss re à
lui multiplié par quatre évidemment ça
fera un point de pib en moins mais comme
le pib oreilles dans le monde
or progresser le montant ce que
j'appelle le panier depuis qu'on
travaille le montant sera lui multiplié
par quatre donc le mode de répartition
quels qu'ils soient fera que moyennement
les retraites versées seront supérieures
évidemment nous en avons beaucoup parlé
il ya des gagnants il ya des perdants
mais il y aura moyennement des gagnants
merci monsieur brunel
oui monsieur le ministre
effectivement on va pas être d'accord
sur sort ce que je vais dire puisque
nous on pense que le système actuel est
un système solidaire voilà et qu'il faut
l'améliorer certainement on est d'accord
là dessus et en même temps on pense
qu'il faut qu'il soit tiré vers le haut
donc avec une retraite qui soit à l'âge
de 60 ans vous partez de l'idée que y'a
plus en plus de personnes qui vont
arriver dans le monde donc beaucoup plus
de citoyens vous pouvez assez 2040 j'ai
déjà dit 2050 le 10 milliards
d'individus dans le monde
ce qui est important ça va des soucis se
révéler au niveau de notre pays puisque
ya augmentation peu près de 2 millions
un million neuf sur tous les sept ans en
plus de citoyens ici il ya plus de
retraités que deux salariés c'est ce que
vous dites donc il faut jouer la
solidarité pour tout le monde et essayer
d'avancer là dessus permettez-moi
essayer de comprendre puisqu'on est sur
cet article numéro 8 et qui parle du
point donc le point d'après monsieur
delevoye c'était un point à la hauteur
de 10 euros et le point à une valeur de
0 55 centime
on est bien d'accord sur cette face à
une carrière complète je vais prendre un
exemple quelqu'un qui a travaillé bon
qui est né en 2004 qui a 16 ans
aujourd'hui qui se met sur le marché du
travail
il travaille donc pour 43 annuités donc
516 mois il va arriver donc à une
retraite je pense à 64 ans lui la 59 ans
donc il va faire quelques années
supplémentaires
quelle va être sa pension à ce niveau là
là il peut déjà le calcul et on peut
déjà pas du bon le calculer avec les
laiteries metz est donc là ya pas encore
fait ses 25 meilleures années et c'est
là que je comprends pas parce que si je
me réfère à ce qu'a dit monsieur lui ce
matin c'est la gouvernance qui va
décider
la valeur du point au fur et à mesure
qu'on va avancer et là on est incapable
de savoir comment ça va fonctionner donc
voilà ma question combien de points là
on cotise on sait par exemple pour un
salaire à l'échelle de 1 3428 et une
cotisation de 6,90 % pour le salarié est
de 8,50 5% pour le patron
ça représente quoi par mois et combien
de points faut-il par mois merci
monsieur bernalicis mais ce sont les
questions effectivement qu'on se pose
autour de cet article 8 sur la valeur du
point sa valeur d'acquisition sa valeur
de 2 services et comment vont évoluer
les différentes les différentes notions
parce que le système actuel qui comporte
des injustices encore une fois tout le
monde en convient il comporte aussi une
certaine stabilité une certaine
prévisibilité qu'on ne retrouve pas avec
votre système par points
et tout à l'heure le ministre a dit
voilà les critères sur lesquels les
points soit valeur d'acquisition aux
valeurs de service sont connus mais est
ce qu'elles peuvent être divergentes
est-ce que la valeur d'acquisition peut
être différente le coefficient qui va
s'appliquer à son évolution peut être
différente de la valeur de service
ça c'est une question qui pourrait être
intéressante de savoir parce que on a
bien vu qu'il y avait un plancher ça
peut pas être inférieur à foison donc ça
peut pas être ça va diminuer
ça peut pas être inférieur à l'inflation
pour la valeur de service si j'ai bien
compris
mais après les deux peuvent être
divergents
d'une année sur l'autre ils peuvent être
quelque part entre l'inflation et le
revenu moyen par tête qui je le rappelle
c'est ai dit tout à l'heure ne sera pas
calculé par l'insee il sera constatée
par l'insee sur la base d'un calcul
défini par le conseil d'état car
sensiblement différent parce que autant
je reconnais le professionnalisme de
l'insee dans sa capacité à élaborer des
calculs qui est qui qui reflète une
réalité
le conseil d'état un peu moins même si
ils sont au moins capable d'avoir un
avis assez tranché sur votre étude
d'impact mais juste pas sûr que ce soit
le métier du conseil d'état que
d'élaborer des modalités de calcul ça me
semble que cette le le cas de l'insee
mais de toute façon vous dites que par
défaut les vals la valeur l'évolution de
la valeur d'acquisition à l'avers de
service seront par ce revenu au moyen
par tête par défaut mais ça veut pas
dire que ce sera tout le temps le cas
puisque vous prévoyez un plancher il
pourra bien modifier être modifiés
chaque année sur proposition du conseil
national des retraites
c'est ce que vous proposez
donc voila moi je sais pas comment
comment vous arrivez à pouvoir dire que
à la fin moyennement ce sera mieux pour
en moyenne pour les gens strictement
rien dire merci nous en venant au vote
sur ces amendements
tout d'abord le 26 821 représentée par
monsieur brunel qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté ensuite des amendements
identiques d'abord le dit 1341 de madame
diallo ce qui est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté ensuite le 5593 présentée
par monsieur minots qui est pour et
contre
il est rejeté nous en venons une autre
série d'amendements identiques sur
laquelle je suis saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe gauche
démocrate et républicaine
le groupe le seul amendement 11 914 il
est signalé dans dans l'assemblée et je
vous propose monsieur alan l'once
ah oui pardon excusez moi j'avais été un
petit peu surpris
le son le 11 1914 c'est la gauche
républicaine qui demande un scrutin
public mais c'est un amendement qui est
porté par qui il ya personne chez vous
dommage pour nous se peut 11 915
monsieur cinieri non oui merci monsieur
le président vous sur le ministre d'un
système d'un système actuel le montant
des pensions est calculé en prenant en
compte les 25 meilleures années de
cotisations pour l'ensemble des assurés
et les six derniers mois pour les agents
publics la réforme introduit à ce sujet
un changement techniquement apparemment
accessoires mais philosophie losique
vous pardon philosophiquement majeur car
elle postule qu'il ne peut y avoir de
retraite par points sans prise en compte
de la totalité de la carrière
professionnelle du salarié ou du
fonctionnaire le système par points est
l'ami prise en compte de la totalité de
la carrière étant
deux sujets distincts qu'on a
systématiquement liés dans le projet
dans le système actuel
un ouvrier qui a commencé sa carrière au
smig puis à progresser comme
contremaître puis comme cadres peuvent
bénéficier d'une pension de retraite
calculée sur ses 25 meilleures années
de la même façon que celui qui est
entrée dans la vie professionnelle comme
cadre en sortant d'une grande école dans
la fonction publique un fonctionnaire
qui a commencé son parcours comme
instituteur et l'a terminée comme
recteur d'académie ça existe touchera la
même retraite que notre recteur
d'académie qui a commencé sa carrière
comme agrégé en sortant de l'école
normale supérieure il n'en sera plus
ainsi dans le nouveau système qu'on nous
propose désormais en prenant en compte
la totalité de la carrière de chacun
le retraité sera irrémédiablement
rattrapé par la passion dont il est
entré dans la vie professionnelle et le
mérite qui l'aura qui au fur et à mesure
de celle ci ne pèsera plus grand chose
on lui rappellera lors de son départ en
retraite qu'il a commencé son métier au
bas de l'échelle
il ne pourra pas prétendre la même
pension que ceux qui ont commencé plus
haut que lui tu as commencé ta carrière
modestement on n'oublie pas pour deux
salariés qui auront les 25 meilleures
années comparable le montant de la
pension de retraite rappellera alain
qu'il a commencé petit à l'autre qu'il a
grâce à son diplôme commencé à une
position plus élevée
est ce un système juste certaine c est
notre système éducatif est censée ouvrir
à tous et sur la base du seul mais rich
laxer delà de belles études merci mr
cinieri alors il avait été indiqué par
monsieur peu lorsqu'il avait déposé que
c est identique
donc il y aura un scrutin public sur ces
amendements le 26 764 c'est vous
monsieur peu oui merci monsieur le
président je vais je vais citer la linea
dont on discute
il ya une phrase qui dit à compter de
l'âge prévu
l'assuré adroit sur sa demande à une
retraite égale au produit des points
inscrits à son compte personnel de
carrière
par la valeur du point fixé à cette date
donc si on résume arrivé à l'âge des qui
dit bon on regarde combien on possède
deux points sur son compte
on regarde la valeur du point à la date
en cours on multiplie le tout et
surprise on obtient son niveau de
pension c'est bien ça vous avez donc
inventé la retraite loterie dans
laquelle il est impossible de savoir au
préalable
combien de retraite on touchera
puisqu'elle dépendra de son nombre de
points et de leur valeur à la date
donnée
on passe donc clairement un système de
cotisations définies
alors vendredi dernier alors qu'on
parlait de ce sujet notre collègue petit
affirmé que cette notion la cotisation
définie n'avait plus beaucoup de sens
dans le futur système ça je sais bien
tout le problème pour nous parce qu'avec
ce système vous remettez en cause le
contrat social clairement établie entre
la société et les assurés qui assure à
chaque futur retraité un niveau de
retraite en fonction des meilleurs
salaires qui sont souvent les dernières
les 25 dernières pour le privé les six
derniers mois pour le public et donc
vous introduisez et c'est bien là le
fondement de votre système vous
introduction être introduisait un doute
une notion totalement aléatoire plus
personne ne saura quelle sera sa
retraite et c'est une invitation je le
répète pour ceux qui en le pourront 2
bénéficie d' aller s'orienter vers la
capitalisation et c'est bien ça
l'objectif in fine et de votre réforme
merci monsieur peu monsieur rapporteur
merci monsieur le président un jeu
je sais bien que le but d opposition et
et de faire peur mais on a l'impression
que au final on arrive le jour de sa
retraite
on nous présente un sac avec des billes
dedans on tira voilà vous vous avez le
bon numéro vous avez le super poids non
mais écoutez
est ce qu'il ya un système aujourd'hui
qui est comme ça est ce que aujourd'hui
je sais c'est comme si on annonçait que
les prix de demain seraient razar total
par rapport aux prix d'aujourd'hui il ya
des évolutions qui se font et à tout
moment les évolutions sont entre
l'évolution du prix et l'évolution des
salaires c'est si on regarde ces
dernières années ça va être entre 1 et 2
% de la valeur du point donc à tout
moment on peut faire une simulation et
on peut faire on peut calculer ce que
donnerait sa retraite en euros
d'aujourd'hui celui qui était à 50 ans
qui accumule qui est que je prenais
l'exemple de quelqu'un qui aurait 2000
euros par mois de salaire brut 2000
euros par mois de salaire brut
avec le taux de cotisation retenu ça
fait 6000 euros de cotisation avec une
valeur d'achat à 10 euros c'est à dire
qu'ils acquièrent chaque année 600
points donc à 50 ans il peut faire la
simulation parce qu'on le verra
l'article 12 à chaque moment pourra
faire une simulation évidemment plus on
est loin de la date d'arrivée plus le
mot - l'évalution l'évaluation est
précise mais on va dire qu'à l'âge de 50
ans à un âge où on commence à se
préoccuper sérieusement de ce que
pourrait être sa retraite
on peut avoir une idée vu le salaire
qu'on a donc vu lé nombre de points
qu'on accumule chaque année au vu de la
valeur du point
l'année considérée avoir une évoluer
vers la scion assez précise de
l'évolution du point et puis c'est faire
par comparaison avec le système actuel
le système actuel qui est des trimestres
auquel faux accorde une valeur qu'il
faut revaloriser suivant l'inflation
depuis l'année où on l'a acquise en
vérifiant que c'est un des 25 meilleurs
on a attient auxquels on peut rajouter
qu'on a changé de métier donc la règle
on l'a on l'a compte bien bien moins
facilement donc moi je vous assure que
le système actuel est plus fin dans son
mode de calcul puisque les trimestre
avec moins de 150 heures travaillées
aujourd'hui ne sont pas calculés
il n'est plus équitable parce que quel
que soit le régime auquel vous
travaillez quel que soit le métier que
vous faites vous êtes vous acquérez des
points de la même façon et il est plus
lisible
parce qu' un nombre de points fois une
valeur du point c'est plus
compréhensible que des trimestre avec
des valeurs du contrô valoriser suivant
l'inflation et auquel on doit on doit
mobile qu'on doit interpréter suivant le
régime auquel on appartient
voilà ce que je voulais dire et puis
madame dalloz loin de moi ou loin de
nous l'idée que le système actuel
tous seraient achetés dans le système
actuel bien sûr que le système actuel
d'abord qu'est par répartition c'est ce
un élément majeur que nous reprenons et
le système actuel a apporté beaucoup de
services si on peut le résumer comme ça
à la question des retraites en france
mais son organisation pas régime avec
des règles différentes avec des prises
en compte d'éléments comme les aimants
de maternité ou de solidarité différente
d'un régime à l'autre en complique
vraiment la compréhension et à
compliquer une forme d'équité donc
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés peut être revenir d'abord sur le
sujet qui a été réouvert sur les 25
meilleures années où la carrière
complète jeu toujours je pense que c'est
intéressant même si j'ai entendu que
vous n'étiez pas toujours très
bienveillant avec l'étude d'impact mais
je pense que c'est intéressant quand
même de s'y reporter à chaque fois qu'on
a des questions comme ça parce qu'elle
était à bloc sont très claires le
tableau 7 d'étude d'impact montre bien
que le calcul sur l'ensemble de la
carrière avec indexation profite
justement aux carrières les plus
linéaire les plus plates et il bénéficie
essentiellement aux petits revenus et
aux revenus modestes qui vont bénéficier
du coeur redistributif de ce système par
répartition et par points par ailleurs
on peux le redire les carrière
ascendante
madame dalloz vous posiez la question
mais il n'y a pas de la retraite c'est
le reflet de la carrière c'est pas le
reflet du niveau d'études
c'est pas le reflet du fait que j'ai eu
la chance de rentrer dans telle
entreprise ou telle autre
donc ça veut dire que si je commence ma
vie professionnelle
et puis que j'ai 2 une dynamique qui est
la mienne une progression qui est la
mienne
et bien c'est cela que va me dire ma
retraite et j'avais eu sentiment je sais
pas si c'est ce que vous vouliez
exprimer en vous écoutant que votre
lecture c'était plutôt dire en fait on
va juste regarder le point d'arrivée de
chacun et on voit à calculer la retraite
sur le point d'arriver
parce que vous faisiez une comparaison
en prenant de carrière moi je pense que
la carrière elle parle à la retraite
elle parle de la carrière complète et
d'ailleurs c'est ça la réalité de notre
système de retraite donc je pouvais pas
être en accord sur votre peau propre et
en même temps je pense que vous ce que
tu es peut-être souligné une idée que
j'ai déjà entendu dans vos rangs sur ces
bancs qui est de dire que le système de
retraites que nous proposons serait un
système qui serait défavorable aux
évolutions de carrière mais je vais vous
dire ce qui la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il faut que j'aie des
évolutions de carrière et puis que ces
évolutions de carrière pour ça marche
bien mais elles soient plutôt vers la
fin c'est à dire qu'il vaut mieux que
mes 25 meilleurs soient mes 25 dernières
pourquoi parce que pour une raison que
le président woerth que les biens et
puis je lui en fais pas grief c'est que
pour des raisons d'équilibré financier
m'ont donné on a décidé de d'indexer
l'ensemble des salaires portés aux
comptes sur l'inflation et pas sur les
salaires
dire que plus mes meilleures années sont
loin de mes dernières années est bien
plus elles ont été des capitaliser -
laval
c'est mathématique on peut en discuter
pendant quatre jours je crois que tout
le monde est d'accord là dessus donc
c'est pour ça que c'est assez ambigu
votre nom mais je ne dis pas que vous
vouliez mettre de côté sa célèbre je
vous dis simplement y est c'est un peu
compliqué c'est comme tout à l'heure
quand on voulait parler des taux de
rendement on peut prendre un prisme et
puisse dire ah bah oui si on prend juste
pris ce nom là on a l'impression que
c'est pas équilibré mais en fait tous
assez dynamique
il ya ça fait longtemps tranquille faut
prendre en compte et on voit bien que
nous ce qu'on propose c'est un âge d
équilibre parce que justement l'a
compris que tout cela était bien mais je
pense que vous si vous l'avez compris
parce que vous avez sur vauban un
certain nombre d'acteurs des réformes
précédentes qui avaient bien vu le sujet
donc je pense que c'est dommage des
relations devraient pouvoir se retrouver
être en accord comment devrait pouvoir
se retrouver avec les élus sur ma gauche
parce que je crois qu'il retrouverait
des éléments de solidarité qui favorise
notamment ceux qui ont les parcours
professionnels les plus plats les plus
lignières et je pense que sur ça on
aurait dû se retrouver en tout cas on
devrait se retrouver j'espère sur ce
texte
merci de m'avoir donné quelques instants
monsieur le président vous merci madame
banier oui pour une fois l'argumentation
donné tout à l'heure par le défenseur de
l'as de l'amendement me fait réagir
il prend d'un côté un agrégé d'un autre
un ouvrier mais qu'on soient agrégées
ouvriers ou d'ailleurs un autre métier
on se retrouve à la même table de
famille au même repas de famille le
dimanche et je vous assure qu'un agrégé
dont on prend les six derniers mois et
un ouvrier dont on prend les 25
meilleures années qui se retrouve avec
un agriculteur qui n'a même pas 700
euros de retraite par mois
eh bien ces gens là qui se retrouve à la
même table de famille le week-end sont
tout à fait conscients des inégalités du
système actuel il faut le rappeler par
ailleurs
j'arrive tout juste j'ai croisé un
chauffeur de taxi là tout à l'heure il
m'a dit il faut que vous parliez de mon
cas il a 62 ans au mois de juin prochain
il m'a dit voilà moi 62 ans je vais
toucher 600 euros
parce que j'ai travailé 150 trimestres
je n'ai pas une carrière tout à fait
complète mais 600 euros si je veux 800
euros je vais devoir travailler jusqu'à
64 ans si je veux me l'euro ce sera
jusqu'à 67 ans voilà le système actuel
est ce qu'il est juste franchement voilà
merci
même monsieur petit monsieur petit mais
pas de mots oui c'est vous ah oui pardon
excusez moi je
anna j'ai eu un problème avec le modem
monsieur va régner c'est vrai oui merci
monsieur le président sommes alors vous
souhaiter que nos débats soient sûrs
plus précis vous souhaitez qu'on soit
bienveillant la mairie tude d'impact
vous souhaitez beaucoup écouté nos
débats soient aussi précis que le texte
mais c'est quand même pas notre faute si
toutes les valeurs essentielles de ce
texto envoyé à des décrets
si pour toutes les règles votre projet
de loi prévoit également des procédures
déception alors quand vous dites non
cotisées voudra la même chose pour tous
nous savons que c'est pas vrai c'est au
mieux un slogan au pire une réelle du
prix en effet la valeur de service du
point
elle devrait être pondéré de l'espérance
de vie de chacune et de chacun car cette
valeur est à multiplier par le nombre de
mois dont une personne un bénéfice et
apprend à connaître leur réelle et là
les écarts de valeur et donc de droit
qui pour chaque euro cotisé va être
monstrueux données sans arrêt confrontée
à des incertitudes à des imprécisions
des flous donc franchement ce projet est
flou de bout en bout alors je vois pas
comment on peut être clair merci
monsieur peu oui d'abord comme un autre
collègue bien parce que quand il ya des
inégalités faut les corriger faut pas
les aggraver
votre projet les aggrave et donc
c'est là toute notre divergence et donc
moi je voudrais revenir sur un argument
qui a été développé par la maman de
monsieur cinieri parce que je suis déjà
intervenu dans un autre article sur le
sujet mais j'ai pas eu de réponse très
franchement quelqu'un qu'à tous les
diplômes et qui rentre tout de suite
dans la vie professionnelle que ce soit
dans le bâtiment comme conducteur de
travaux dans la banque comme directeur
d' agence ou dans le commerce comme chef
de boutiques il va avoir une carrière
puisque la retraite sera calculé tout au
long de la carrière qui lui sera
relativement bénéfique mais celui et on
n'en connais plein qui rentrent masson
après un apprentissage qui par son
courage par son abnégation devient
contremaître puis conducteur de travaux
ussel gelé en mémoire je la connais bien
qui est rentré comme couturière qui est
devenu chef d'atelier qui est maintenant
responsable de boutique ou encore un
autre qui est rentré comme guichetier à
la banque qui a été chef de bureau au
cac finit directeur d'une agence
bancaire
tous ces gens du basson à à l'employé de
banque en passant par la couturière qui
sont rentrés en bas de l'échelle et qui
ont gravi peu à peu les échelons
aujourd'hui leur retraite elle est
calculée sur les 25 dernières années
meilleure année 25 meilleures années et
aujourd'hui leur retraite rsa calculée
sur toute la carrière est donc celui qui
est rentré
bardé de diplômes assez haut dans
l'échelle sociale sera bénéficiaire
celui qui a démarré en bas et qui par
son mérite son abnégation son travail
aura grandi les échelons lui sera
pénalisé c'est ça votre système
et il est extrêmement inégale et
extrêmement pénalisant pour la valeur
travail
merci monsieur peu monsieur barry 6
merci messieurs prison il arrive donc
très importants qui ont été des exemples
côté donné par le collègue stéphane peu
à l'instant qui devrait faire réfléchir
sur les bancs de la majorité devrait
revenir sur l'exemple donné par la
collègue tout à l'heure de ce chauffeur
de taxi qui s'il veut avoir 1000 euros
devra travailler jusqu'à 67 ans mais
dans votre système je suis pas sûr
qu'ils doivent 3 y est beaucoup moins
longtemps pour avoir le même niveau
parce qu'ici la paix une carrière
complète
s'il a commencé à travailler tard il n'a
pas accumulé deux points et du coup il
dépendra aussi du coefficient
d'ajustement cire de l'âge à partir de
lait qu'elle s'appliquera une décote une
surcote est donc même si il cumule
beaucoup de points parce qu il veut
cotiser plus ou qu'il a fait un métier
qui lui permettait de cotiser plus de
toutes façons il aura pas suffisamment
de points pour avoir un montant de
pension qui soit acceptable et donc
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va continuer
à bosser parce que si en plus ils se
retrouvent en dessous de l'âge
déquilibre que vous allez faire
augmenter évoluer dans le temps je suis
pas sûr qu'il arrivera à 67 ans avec
quelque chose à 1000 euros et il aura
même pas vos milles euros promis
puisqu'il aura pas lui-même de carrière
complète donc je suis pas sûr que le
chauffeur de taxi ils doivent vous
remercier d'avoir porter sa parole dans
l'hémicycle de la sorte parce que lui il
a plutôt intérêt à ce que ce soit des
gens comme nous qui gouverna le pays
pour comprendre charles
les carrières hachées
et les clairières mais c'est bien le p6
pour fuir oui mais c'est la réalité
et de toute façon de toute façon
heureusement que votre l'essentiel de
votre réforme ne s'appliquera qu'à
partir de 2022 puisqu'on pourra plus
facilement revenir dessus
ceci étant dit mais il faut quand même
bien comprendre il faut quand même bien
comprendre que tout ça est
incompréhensible
donc je récapitule on récapitule la
valeur d'acquisition du point on ne la
connaît pas et on ne connaît pas son
évolution
on sait juste qu'elle peut pas baisser
la valeur de service de 32
transformation du point on la connaît
pas et on ne sait pas comment elle va
évoluer le coït et merci messieurs
président oui je comprends pas cette
opposition systématique enfin sur le la
retraite par points parce que cette
retraite par quand elles existent elles
existent sont les les retraites
complémentaires agirc-arrco ircantec ce
sont déjà des régimes par points est
aujourd'hui la gouvernance de ces
retraites complémentaires
il y a des syndicats de salariés
d'ailleurs des syndicats qui s'opposent
à la réforme
et pourtant ils se mettent d'accord et
ils ont ils arrivent à des accords
nationaux pour justement avoir une
soutenabilité du point donc où est le
problème
franchement je ne comprends pas cette
opposition pour skier également des 25
meilleures années
on l'a dit on le redit systématiquement
la base c'est déjà ça la moyenne c'est
la moitié de la moyenne des revenus des
25 ans c'est pas la totalité des revenus
la base de calcul premièrement ensuite
vous avez la complémentaire qui vaut
pour 30 40 % donc aujourd'hui il ya une
bonne part de la retraite qui est
calculée par points voilà et quand vous
êtes polypensionnés
c'est encore pire parce que les 25
meilleures années vous les avez pas là
où vous avez les meilleurs revenus
puisque c'est au prorata des durées de
cotisation de chaque régime
merci madame dalloz sur le sujet des
polypensionnés je demande à voir on
n'est pas encore assez article là et je
pense que sur le sujet il y aura
beaucoup de précision avoir pour venir
pour en revenir à l'exemple du chauffeur
de taxi qui nous mobilise un moment cet
après midi partons du principe que c'est
un travailleur indépendant le cas des
travailleurs indépendants on l'a abordée
largement dans le cadre de l'article 5
de mémoire me semble-t-il
la réalité c'est quoi c'est que celui
qui a effectivement une carrière sans
cotiser toute toute la durée de sa
carrière il aura un minimum
oui lors un minimum mais quand même pas
62 ans il faut pas qu'il rêve c'est pas
62 ans qui l'aura sans minimum
il aura une décote au moins jusqu'à 65
premier aspect est celui son collègue
qui a fait une carrière complète en tant
que chauffeur de taxi qui a cotisé toute
sa vie il va cotiser pour avoir la même
retraite à laquelle il pouvait prétendre
aujourd'hui et encore il va cotiser
beaucoup plus elle travaillera plus
longtemps si c'est ça votre conception
de l'équilibré de l'équité moi je pense
que celui qui a travaillé toute sa
carrière est bien avec une colle un taux
de cotisation il est logique qu'ils
aient une retraite supérieure à celui
qui n'a pas cotisé toute sa vie et qui
lui pourrait à prétendre à une retraite
minimum et c'est pour ça que encore une
fois la notion de solidarité dans la
retraite de base
je suis favorable mais on est en train
avec ce dispositif alors que les 25
meilleures années constituaient un
niveau de retraite suffisamment
important on est en train avec votre
dispositif sur la tonalité de cartes de
la carrière de réduire concevrez mans de
façon considérable le niveau des
pensions auxquelles pourront prétendre
les françaises et les français dans les
années à venir
merci même de la mort maintenant nous
allons voter sur ces amendements il vous
rappelle qu'il ya une demande de scrutin
public qui a été faite par le groupe de
la gauche démocrate et républicaine
amendement en 1915 est identique
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat votre 75 exprimé 64 majorité 38
pour 14 contre 61 ils sont rejetés alors
nouveau nom avec nous en venons à des
amendements pouvant donner lieu à une
discussion commune
le groupe la france a soumises demande
un scrutin public sur le 24 999 et ce
qu'ils demandent et le est toujours le
même groupe sur le 24 980 de ils sont
annoncés dans l'hémicycle alors tout
d'abord sur le 24 999 madame taurine oui
je remercie donc concernant cet
amendement qui est un amendement de
repli
nous considérons qu'il est nécessaire
d'y voir plus clair concernant
l'évolution de la valeur du point et
donc nous proposons que l'insee
détermine un indicateur solide qui
intègre à la fois l'évolution des
salaires et l'évolution du capital afin
de permettre une réévaluation plus
favorable aux travailleuses et aux
travailleurs par conséquent à l'alinéa 2
après le mot points nous proposons
d'insérer la phrase suivante déterminé
par l'institut national de la
statistique et des études économiques
sur la base d'une combinaison entre
l'évolution des salaires et l'évolution
du capital après avis du conseil
économique social et environnemental je
vous remercie
merci madame la députée sur le chez vous
qui présentait le 24 999 c'est une
discussion lance monsieur bernalicis oui
on a 4 982 pas non ils sont en
discussion commune c'est le sujet de
fameux indicateurs de revenu moyen par
tête on propose la 2de donné la création
d'un indicateur
oui pourquoi pas mais à l'insee pas au
conseil d'état aux gens qui savent
calculer les indicateurs qui savent
statistiquement à quelle réalité ça
correspond et pas un machin inventé sur
un coin de table qui vous permet qui
d'ailleurs devait au départ être salaire
moyen par tête qui est devenu le revenu
moyen par tête qui visiblement
des premières indications premiers
éléments qu'on a serait moins favorable
en termes de dynamique que le salaire
moyen par tête même si j'ai bien
expliqué si j'ai bien entendu par dont
les explications alambiquées du ministre
disant que l'un comportant l'autre la
dynamique serait quand même au
rendez-vous et que finalement ce sera
quand même positif en tout cas on
préférait que si un indicateur il soit
fait par les gens qui savent les
construire et pas juste par le par le
par le conseil d'état non c'est par le
conseil d'état que vous ne prévoyez dans
votre tête nomique pas celle c'est le
cas c'est inscrit dans votre texte noir
sur blanc que l'indicateur sera
constatée constatée par l'insee les mots
ont une importance si c'est cela que
vous avez mis dans votre texte
bien que ça veut dire quelque chose
constatée par l'insee sur la base d'une
modalité de calcul défini par le conseil
d'état d'accord ok c'est pas exactement
la même chose que indicateurs définis
par l'insee est calculé par l'insee est
constatée par l'insee c'est pas la même
chose voilà bon après c'est à vous de
voir si vous voulez bidouiller les
chiffres et avoir des choses qui de
toute façon sur lesquelles on ne pourra
pas se reposer parce que vous dites même
dans votre propre amendement fin de
votre propre texte pardon que c'est la
valeur qu'on retiendra par défaut mais
pas la valeur qu'on retiendra
dans l'absolu d'ailleurs cette valeur
elle sera discutée chaque année dans le
conseil national des retraites
la seule garantie qu'on a c'est que ça
baissera pas maigre garantie vu qu'elle
coefficient d'ajustement qui peut bouger
qu'il ya tout un tas d'autres paramètres
qui peuvent bouger
donc voilà nous proposons modestement de
pointer du doigt le fait que vous ne
vouliez pas mettre des indicateurs
fiables en place si monsieur banale si
ce monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président donc je
précise que c'est dans cette série que
yann l'amendement 25000 déposée par le
député bernad et 6 qui vient de prendre
la parole donc moi il me semble que
c'est pas quantité qui fait qualité
parce que là en gros vous venez de
mettre en cause j'ai pas tout à fait
suivi le tremblement terre si vous
remettez en cause l'indépendance du
conseil d'état ou l'indépendance de
l'insee mais que ce soit là où que ce
soit l'eau tout que ce soit les deux ça
me semble suffisamment grave pour être
pointée parce que c'est quand même des
professionnels au service de l'état
et donc je trouve ça particulièrement
choquant ensuite sur le l'amendement lui
même vous proposez madame taurine
d'abord sur la le coefficient de
revalorisation du point c'est l'article
9 on est un petit peu en avance ce sua
le sur leur mais sur le fond en prenant
en compte l'évolution du capital
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qui va se
passer
les années où il va y avoir des forte
croissance vous allaient fortement
augmenter la valeur d'acquisition du
point donc ce qui va mécaniquement
donner moins de points à cotisation
égale aux salariés qui sont en activité
est l'année du retournement au moment de
ce qu'ils vont liquider leur retraite la
valeur du point
va être fortement baissé puisque vous
vous indiquez le capital comme mode
d'intégration dans dans le temps dans
cet index donc le capital est une notion
qui ne reflète pas les revenus c'est
pour ça que nous nous avons retenu le
revenu moyen par tête qui sera un
agrégat des salaires des deux ce qui est
versé aux un haut fonctionnaire et puis
aux revenus des indépendants
ça nous semble beaucoup plus fidèle à la
réalité que d'intégrer le capital avec
la variabilité qui peut être la sienne
pour revenir sur des éléments qui ont
été évoquées avant l'exemple de monsieur
peu qui n'est plus là mais sur la
carrière qui serait ascendante serait
perdante par rapport au système actuel
je vous rappelle que carrière ascendante
donc on va dire si elle est ascendante
ça veut dire que les 25 meilleures
années sont les 25 dernières années
ça veut dire que il ya quand même c'est
érosion liés à la comparaison évolution
suivant l'inflation évolution suivant
les revenus
et donc ça fait quand même une sacrée
perte de pouvoir d'achat ou de gain de
points retraite donc le système actuel
effectivement dans le système actuel
pour celui qui a une carrière ascendante
monopensionnés elle va être elle va être
moins ascendante en termes de
transcription dans les droits à retraite
que dans le système précédemment ça
c'était une réalité mais il ya aussi un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens
on soit des carrières plates soit des
carrières qui peuvent être qu'ils
peuvent connaître des accidents c'est
celui qui a commencé une belle carrière
et puis suite à un licenciement suite à
un problème de maladie qui va à 45 ans
va avoir un sérieux décrochage dans sa
carrière ou alors des personnes qui peut
être après un burn-out en ayant été
cadres de haut niveau décide de se
reconvertir on envoie un certain nombre
nous dans nos campagnes de gens qui
s'installe comme artisan et donc la
comparaison lié la revalorisation liée
sur l'inflation dans le système actuel
est très défavorable par rapport à
l'évolution des revenus et ses revenus
anciens sont particulièrement sous
valorisées dans le système actuel et le
système indexé sur le revenu moyen par
tête corrige mieux ce genre de situation
donc défavorable à ces amendements
merci monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président bon ce sujet du
duo revenu moyen par tête je suis bien
ici c'est l'article d'après bon mais je
comprends qu'on parle de 8 du neuf aux 9
et puis loin du 25 ce qui facilite pas
forcément toujours la vie de ceux qui
vous répondent
malgré leur bonne volonté mais en tout
cas moi je vais essayer de vous répondre
si vous voulez sur ce revenu moyen
d'activités par tête d'abord vous dire
que c'est pas une grande surprise que de
se dire il y aura un décret qui sera
prêt au conseil d'état
c'est sur ce fond extrêmement rassurant
d'ailleurs le rapporteur a souligné que
vous pouvez pas à la fois venir nous
expliquer régulièrement tout ce qu'il ya
dans le rapport du conseil d'état
soulignant en même temps son
indépendance et sa capacité à parler au
gouvernement de ce qu'il devrait faire
sans doute juridiquement mieux et puis
en même temps lorsque
même conseil d'état un décret sera pris
au conseil d'état sur le revenu moyen
d'activités aulas avoir l'air d'être
d'une grande inquiétude va encore une
fois on a besoin de cohérence moi
j'entends que vous soyez en attente de
cette cohérence de la part de vos
interlocuteurs mais c'est vrai que on
peut imaginer que cela soit réciproque
l'autre point que je voulais partager
avec vous c'est que l'insee qui est un
organisme indépendant suis déjà le
revenu moyen des salariés
le revenu moyen des fonctionnaires et
celui des indépendants donc voilà ça
doit pas non plus faire l'objet à mon
avis d'une interrogation fondamentale
mais je peux l'entendre la
représentation nationale que se dire que
voilà un organisme indépendant qui
dispose déjà de trois indicateurs qui
seront les principales composantes de
l'indicateur voire même les uniques
puisque c'est les 3 catégories d'actifs
les trois catégories d'actifs qui vont
constituer l'indicateur du revenu moyen
activités on voit bien qu a priori dean
c'est dans sa compétence et sa son
expertise va trouver la solution pour
suivre cet indicateur de façon
indépendante alors c'est vrai que je me
suis dit bon on voit que c'est un sujet
parce que l'on a parlé en commission on
a reparlé y six fois bon c'est pas être
un sujet forcément à mon avis inquiétant
parce qu'on voit bien que l'organisme
qui va suivre tout ça a non seulement
les moyens mais les outils et les
informations pour suivre le revenu
d'activité moyen par tête
enfin je voudrais comme vous redire
monsieur quand ils disent que malgré vos
dénégations il y est clairement indiqué
que les deux valeurs de service et
d'achat suivent la même réévaluation
annuelle
alors vous avez pointé le par défaut bah
oui par défaut pourquoi par défaut
monsieur le député parce que depuis plus
de deux semaines je tente mais
visiblement je je je m'y emploie mais je
n'y arrive pas toujours
je tente de vous expliquer qu'il faut
faire confiance à la gouverneuse la
démocratie sociale je tente de vous
expliquer je croyais que moi de ce
côté-là des musiques on y était sensible
est favorable je tente de vous expliquer
que les partenaires sociaux sont
capables de prendre de bonnes décisions
je tente de vous expliquer que si on
veut donner
de l'espace à la démocratie sociale il
faut lui donner des responsabilités et
pas uniquement ceux payés de mots eh
bien c'est ce que fait le gouvernement
avec le projet de loi merci messieurs
alors monsieur bernard 6 oui merci
monsieur président deux points
premièrement sur le conseil d'état c'est
intéressant que vous parliez du conseil
d'état puisque il fait partie de l'objet
de la commission denquête que je préside
sur l'indépendance les obstacles
l'indépendance du pouvoir judiciaire et
nous auditionnons la semaine prochaine
d'ailleurs le vice président du conseil
d'état je vous invite à venir monsieur
le rapporteur puisque willy à un débat
il y à un débat sur l'impartialité et
l'indépendance du conseil d'état dans ce
pays
les membres du conseil d'état ne sont
pas reconnus comme étant des magistrats
ce sont des non magistrats la différence
des juges administratifs par exemple il
ya une dualité entre la fonction de
conseil et la fonction juridictionnelle
qui peut porter à question et qui peut
porter à confusion par la notion
d'indépendance qu'on peut avoir une
séparation des pouvoirs ce sont des
débats qui ont toutes leur noblesse
donc ne les balaye pas d'un revers de la
main en disant que selon moi le conseil
d'état serait pas indépendant ou peu
indépendant etc
et quant à la vie à la vie qui l'a rendu
sur l'étude d'impact et sur le projet de
loi je n'ai pas dit qu'il l'avait fait
en toute indépendance
nous avons même dit nous avons même dit
si le conseil d'état en arrive à ces
conclusions l'a vu son positionnement
vu les conditions de nomination c'est
que quand même vous allez vachement mal
travaillé 1
c'est ça la réalité c'est ça la réalité
objective donc moi je me fais pas de
commande idéalise pas ce que peut être
le conseil d'état je ne le jeu non plus
je fais pas d'acrimonie particulière sur
sur ses membres n'empêche qu'il faut
raison garder quand on quand on en parle
et puis sur les indicateurs
moi je crois une nouvelle fois qu' il
est intéressant de savoir quand on parle
des points de mettre tout de suite les
indicateurs d'air vous décorer les un
certain nombre d'éléments qui font qu'on
n'y comprend plus grand chose à la fin
et vous dites la démocratie sociale il
faut qu'elle fonctionne il faut qu'elles
fonctionnent mais très bien mais à ce
moment là pourquoi vous cloisonné à 14%
du pib c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est
pas moi qui le dit
c'est l'avis du conseil d'état le petit
13,6 jeu si je dis pas de bêtises du
côté des tas qui vous indiquent
d'ailleurs qu'il faut à vérifier dans
vos calculs que le chômage des plus de
65 ans masculins maillot vert merci
monsieur le président vous créer un
régime universel mais c'est un régime
universel avec des sous régime c'est un
sujet quand même qui pose qui pose
problème mais je crois pas qu'on puisse
puisque vous avez beaucoup parlé de
carrière hachée ou rt je crois pas qu'on
puisse construire tout un système autour
des carrières hachées ouverte et on peut
améliorer
la justice sur le sujet mais enfin il
faut savoir ce que c'est qu'une carrière
hachée ouverte et c'est pas uniquement
des personnes à qui ça a été imposée
c'est aussi des personnes qui ont décidé
d'arrêter de travailler ont repris leur
travail c'est pas toujours des personnes
qui vivent des situations sociales
extrêmement compliqué c'est aussi des
personnes qui ont choisi il ya tout cela
même s'il ya beaucoup de femmes dans ces
carrières heurtées par ailleurs ça veut
dire aussi des personnes qui n'ont pas
aujourd'hui dans le système
d'aujourd'hui suffisamment cotisé donc
et ou en tout cas validé plutôt
suffisamment de trimestres pour en
arriver là mais très souvent mais c'est
au-delà donc des trimestres qui sont
validées pour des raison d'interruptions
d'interruption en termes de maternité en
terme de chômage dans les régimes dans
le régime général mais aussi dans un
certain nombre de régimes
complémentaires
même si même si c'est pas vrai et c'est
pas les mêmes règles dans tous les
régimes on a et donc pour éviter cela
pour avoir des périodes qui ne sont pas
cotisé qui ne sont pas content et il
faut vraiment avoir réellement arrêté
arrêté sa carrière
donc il est assez naturel aussi un
moment donné que la retraite réplique ça
la carrière a été construite comme cela
il ya beaucoup de d'éléments de justice
qui ont permis de compléter un certain
nombre d'arrêts in fine et il est assez
logique dans la retraite on retrouve un
peu que le fait qu'il ya des personnes
qui ont travaillé à temps plein ou en
tout cas qui ont cotisé et qui ont
régularisé tous leurs trimestres et les
autres cétacés assez logique
quant au fait que ça permet de partir à
64 quand on partait à 67
on est le seul pays au monde entre nous
qui réforme ses retraites en partant
plus tôt
je suis et je suis un peu un peu étonné
d'autant plus que c'est pas 67 encore
vous le savez monsieur le ministre
presque 67 mais ce sera bientôt bientôt
67 donc c'est une drôle de manière me
semble-t-il de faire vous pouviez faire
plus injecter sans doute un peu plus de
justice sociale il en fallait il fallait
poursuivre les travaux sur le sujet mais
mais faire tout un système uniquement
pour répondre aux questions des
carrières heurtées ou h et non
merci monsieur le président je vais
parler avec pondération et je vais
parler d'eux modération monsieur berlin
silice vous dites que ça veut rien dire
ce que je dis et vous me dites que la
moyenne
une moyenne dans une répartition ça veut
rien dire il ya que ça qui veut dire
quelque chose
si on a un système par répartition ça
veut dire que dans l'adn que cette année
sera l'année 1946 ou que cette année
soit l'année 2020 ou 2070 le problème de
la répartition c'est qu'on doit faire
une moyenne et cette moyenne et va être
pondéré parce que si elle était une
moyenne simple ça serait effectivement
ce que j'ai dit qu'ils étaient
égalitaire tout à l'heure si à tout le
monde la même retraite
ce serait à peu près mille 600 euros par
mois en ce moment et ça serait à
l'échéance de 2050 ça sera à peu près 2
mis un peu plus de 2000 euros par mois
c'est à dire si on divise l'ensemble des
cotisations prévues par l'ensemble des
retraités prévu des pensionnés prévu or
cette moyenne 7 ce mode de calcul que
nous faisons et qui est fait aujourd'hui
c'est une manière de diviser entre un
panier entre des gens et aujourd'hui il
faut faire une moyenne pondérée ça veut
dire quelque chose c'est à dire qu'on
pondère la moyenne en fonction de ce que
les gens ont cotisé en fonction des
efforts qu'ils ont faits en fonction des
enfants qu'ils ont eus en fonction de la
pénibilité qu'ils ont eu donc dire que
on travaille sur une moyenne
ça veut dire quelque chose c'est même la
seule question et je répète ce que j'ai
dit ce matin vous ne pouvez pas analysé
un système par répartition si vous
partez d'exemple individuels ou des
amplis catégorielles vous j'ai été très
surpris d'ailleurs tout à l'heure que
monsieur coquerel utilise le mot les
gens qui ont accumulé tout au long de
leur vie ils vont être pénalisés par ce
que nous faisons mais qui accumule c'est
la capitalisation la répartition c'est
dans l'année m jeudi vise l'ensemble de
ceux qui rentrent par l'ensemble de ceux
qui en ont besoin et c'est une moyenne
pondérée par les mérites de chacun
voilà tout le monde a pu s'exprimer je
vous propose que nous possédions vote
sur ces deux amendements il y aura deux
votes
les deux par scrutin public chacun a pu
regagner sa place je suis sempastous
c'est bon allez le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat sur ce premier amendement le 60
74 autant 74 exprimé majorité et 38 pour
4 contre 70 sur le deuxième amendement
le 24 980 2 il ya deux amendements
monsieur devienne le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat votants ce centre est
d'exprimer ce 112 majorité 37 pour 4
contre 68 il est rejeté
le 41 1095 madame taurine
je vous remercie donc par cet amendement
nous souhaitons assurer aux retraités
des vieux jours digne et donc il nous
considérons qu'il est nécessaire
d'inscrire dans la loi qu'il faut
garantir leur niveau de vie et qu'ils ne
soient pas impactés par leur départ à la
retraite et donc à l'alinéa 2 après le
mot carrière nous souhaitons insérés les
mots suivants de façon à garantir une
pension de retraite lui garantissant un
maintien de son niveau de vie
je vous remercie merci même taurine
monsieur le rapporteur oui merci
monsieur le président madame la députée
taurine nous avons d'ores et déjà
adoptée à l'article 1er un objectif de
garantie d'un niveau de vie satisfaisant
et nous avons même rajouté et digne
ne confondons pas les objectifs et les
principes du système universel qui était
justement qui relevait du chapitre
premier avec les outils pour les mettre
en place qui sont ceux du chapitre 2
donc défavorable
merci monsieur le président madame la
député tory naples était d'un point
complémentaire pour expliquer mon avis
défavorable par rapport à ce qu'a dit le
rapporteur le rapport exact en fait du
niveau de vie des retraités par rapport
aux actifs a vocation à être déterminée
par la gouvernance du système universel
que nous évoquions tout à l'heure au
travers de justement ses marges de
manoeuvre et ces périmètres d'action
donc laissons lui ces périmètres
d'action à cette gouvernance et faisons
confiance à démocratie sociale avis
défavorable merci je mets aux voix cet
amendement avis défavorable de monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur qui
est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté un amendement identique le
25 1271 je me suis avariée oui merci
monsieur le président un amendement pour
supprimer le mécanisme de calcul de la
pension par point auquel nous sommes
opposés je vois qu'on a suffisamment dit
dans la mesure où ce mécanisme d'abord
pour effet de calculer le montant de la
pension sur l'ensemble de la carrière
plutôt que sur les meilleures années
alors si on prend par exemple un salarié
qui commence sa carrière à 1500 euros
bruts mensuels avec une hypothèse de
revalorisation annuelle du salaire de
1,5 pour cent par an dont je vais vous
inviter tous les nombreux calculs qui
suivent en tout cas si la retraite est
calculée sur la base des 25 meilleures
années
il aurait au final 1692 euros brut par
mois
si la retraite est calculée sur
l'ensemble de la carrière il se retrouve
avec 1470 euros brut par mois
voilà un exemple concret qui dit bien ce
qu'il en est réellement
donc dans le système à points le calcul
la retraite sur l'ensemble de la
carrière indépendamment qu'ils soient
points c'est vraiment le fait que ce
soit sur l'ensemble de la carrière pas
sur les 25 meilleures années pour ce
salarié reviendrait une perte de
retraite de 222 euros brut par mois soit
2600 64 euros bruts par an par ailleurs
le système par points est aussi un
mécanisme qui enferme l'assuré dans les
phases les moins favorables la carrière
on l'a dit à plusieurs reprises pour ce
n'est pas du tout ça ne valorise pas les
personnes qui font preuve de mérites qui
évoluent dans leurs statuts un ouvrier
qui qui progresse qui au final gagner à
moins que celui qui dit qui commence sa
carrière en tant que cadres dont c est
un système qui abroge tout misé
dimension méritocratique dans le calcul
de la de la pension dans une conséquence
étonnant venant de gouvernement libéral
et qui promet la réussite individuelle
vous globalement vous baisser l'ensemble
des retraites
comme vous l'avez fait pour les
prestations sociales et dans le même
temps que vous le vouliez ou non je vais
vous le redire vous avez baissé les
impôts sur les plus riches
l'impôt sur la fortune c'est toujours le
même principe qui reviennent de bout à
l'autre
merci monsieur le député merci monsieur
députés sur ces amendements identiques
il ya une demande de de ce que tu un
public qui a été expliqué par le groupe
la france a soumises et ils sont
annoncés dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
sur le cac à 1181 malades taurine
je vous remercie donc nous l'avons dit
nous sommes entièrement posée cet
article et par conséquent nous demandons
ici la suppression des alinéa 4 à 8
jours merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président donc
monsieur habib ranni par cet amendement
vous supprimer l'ensemble des modalités
des conditions des points retraite donc
l'acquisition des points retraite par
les cotisations d'une part mais aussi
l'acquisition des points au titre des
interruptions de carrière et des droits
familiaux
c'est ceux qui sont aux alinéas 6 7 et 8
ou des points attribués pour prendre en
compte les situations de handicap ou
pour garantir une retraite minimale à
1000 euros
donc je pense que c'est un objectif que
que vous souhaitiez met donc nous en
tous les cas nous y sommes absolument
défaveur merci monsieur monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président oui monsieur
le député à béragne et moi je te tuera
un peu stupéfait je vous avoue quand je
lis les exposés des amendements de tous
ceux qui sur les bancs de la gauche
s'oppose au système de retraite par
points des fois je me dis mais est-ce
que vous avez communiqué vous vos
opposition au système de retraite
parfois aux partenaires sociaux
est ce qu'ils savent que vous êtes
fondamentalement opposés à la retraite
par points parce qu'il faut pas hésiter
à leur dire parce que en fait ils gèrent
un système parfois que vous connaissez
bien et donc moi je suis étonné par la
façon dont vous explique m seulement
c'est pas intéressant pour les salariés
mais en plus c'est profondément injuste
donc en fait si je vous été amené à vous
lire à vous prendre au pied de la lettre
j'en serai amené à croire que les
partenaires sociaux gérard système
profondément injuste pour 70% des
français qui sont les salariés qui ont
entre 40 et 60% de retraite
complémentaire pour l'agirc arrco donc
moi j'avoue que j'ai du mal à vous
suivre monsieur député bernier donc j'ai
un avis défavorable
merci alors monsieur bernalicis monsieur
le ministre bon vous savez bien que
c'est pas les syndicats qui décident
eux-mêmes de mettre en place le régime
agirc arrco oudéa certain nombre de ces
règles etc
les syndicats ne sont pas le
gouvernement ce sont les gouvernements
successifs qui ont pris ces décisions de
les mettre dans ce cadre là pour prendre
en compte les primes parce que pendant
tout un temps on a on a arrêté de
monter les salaires on augmente et que
les primes et on l'a fait à la fois dans
le privé et dans le public
puis au bout d'un moment on s'est dit
oui mais quand même comme on augmente
les primes s'est pas pris dans le conte
dans le cadre des calculs de retraite
donc on a mis en place des
complémentaires et on arrive à la
situation actuelle alors oui pour faire
plus simple on a mis en place des
systèmes par point mais on voit bien
comment vous voulez généraliser ce
système là de sorte à ce que ce soit les
les partenaires sociaux qui discutent de
même de comment ils vont se faire hara
kiri comment ils vont se saigner ils
vont se couper un bras une jambe plutôt
à un orteil à ils vont avoir le choix
c'est sûr ils vont discuter entre eux
sachant que j'ai quand même l'impression
monsieur le ministre ce peut être une
impression que les partenaires sociaux
comme vous dites oh les organisations
syndicales sont quand même
majoritairement opposés à votre réforme
de retraite par points ou alors on a mal
regardé qui était signataire des tracts
d'intersyndicale on a mal vu qu'ils
étaient dans la rue on a mal compris
sans doute on doit être assez idiot
quand à 50 à ce qu'ils sachent le fait
que ici sur ses côtés du banc on est
opposé au système par pont c'est pas une
nouveauté vous pouvez le dire peut même
leur dirais de leur répéter qu'ils
sachent bien qu'ils aient pour un
système pas de retraite universel soit
disant universel pourri c'est à dire le
vôtre et qui pour une réforme des
retraites progressiste merci monsieur
aviragnet oui je crois monsieur le
ministre que j'ai été particulièrement
clair dans l'exposé de l'amendement
la question que je que je conteste le
fait que vous preniez l'ensemble de la
carrière pour le calcul et non pas les
25 meilleures années je crois que je lui
ai dit et on est bien d'accord alors ne
détournez pas ce que je dis et moi ce
qui me rend stupéfait et qui m'arrache
les tripes je vais vous le dire ce qui
m'arrache les tripes c'est que vous
baissiez les retraites à tout le monde
est bon lorsque vous êtes en train de
faire et quand on voit ce que vous avez
distribué aux grandes fortunes de ce
pays
c'est absolument ignobles merci monsieur
à vianne et donc nous allons il n'y a
pas deux nous allons procéder au vote
et vous n'avez pas demandé monsieur
petit vous à nous allons procéder au
vote sur ces amendements identiques
il ya un demandes de scrutins publics
bien sûr
alors tout le monde a pu regagner sa
place ce policier
voilà le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votants 71 expriment et 71 majorité 36
pour 6 contre 65 qu'ils sont rejetés
le cese 1726 madame taurine donc par cet
amendement va nous continuons à demander
la suppression donc ici la suppression
de l'alinéa 4 je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur merci
messieurs présent je reviendrai pas sur
l'alinéa 4 dans lui-même qui définit que
les points inscrits au compte personnel
de carrière et comment ils vont
s'acquérir ensuite sur les années mais à
5 6 7 et 8 mai revenir sur les propos de
monsieur bernalicis comme quoi les
partenaires sociaux se sont pas ou qui
mettent en place un système par points
mais je vous invite à rencontrer des
historiens du système social en france
et que la cgt était un des éléments
moteurs de création de l'agirc et de que
fo est un des éléments moteurs de
l'arrco et que ça a été défini par des
système par points donc ça il faut le
rappeler
et puis monsieur avira nié toute la
carrière en compte toute la carrière je
crois qu'il est parti
agir et archos et sur toute la carrière
est qu on baisserait les retraites pour
tout le monde mais arrêtons de dire ça
le montant des pensions versées sera
sensiblement le même
avant qu'après le nombre de cotisants le
nombre de pensionnés le même avant
qu'après c'est simplement la répartition
qui n'est plus qu'il n'est plus la même
donc absolument défavorable à ces
suppressions de dieu merci monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président même a dit
le rapporteur
merci alors monsieur petit
oui c'est quand même difficile de faire
dire qu'on va baisser la retraite à tout
le monde alors que le montant je prends
2050 l'exemple que j'ai pris depuis ce
matin depuis une semaine le montant le
montant pas le pourcentage de pib
le montant va être multipliée quatre
fois plus vite que le nombre de
retraités donc où passe l'argent comme a
demandé le rapporteur à un moment au
milieu de la nuit quand il y avait plus
grand monde
donc arretez de dire que nous baissons
la retraite à tout le monde et arrêtez
de aussi de nous prendre sur les
sentiments enfin nous nous avons
réfléchi nous nous nous avons travaillé
le modem il part il travaille depuis dix
ans sur ce sujet donc je veux bien qu'on
soit pas d'accord je sais très bien qu'à
gauche vous voulez qu'on augmente des
cotisations on l'a compris
nous avons un autre système mais ne
dites pas que ce système change les
grands équilibres de la répartition
l'entrée des cotisations n'est
absolument pas transformé par notre loi
sauf en plus sauf en plus puisque nous
passons de 1 passe à 3 passes et que
nous passons à 28 % et le nombre de
retraités ne change pas puisque ça c'est
la démographie et nous un nous nous
remontons les nounous nous garantissons
que les plus faibles que les plus
faibles soient soient garanties a un
minimum et nous coupons nous plafonnons
les très hautes
alors on peut nous dire on peut aller
chercher l'exemple de jacqueline de
robert de gérard à lui il est comme si
il est comme ça mais sur le global sur
le global
il faut arrêter de dire que les pensions
vont baisser c'est complètement faux
mathieu rifains oui
on va continuer de vous dire que les
pensions vont baisser et on va continuer
d'expliquer pourquoi on est opposé à
cette retraite par points quand vous
baissez la part des retraites dans le
pib alors que vous savez qu'il va y
avoir des centaines de milliers de
retraités supplémentaire vous l'apc de
14% à 12 8%
il ya quelque chose là qui est presque
indépendant de la retraite à points
c'est qu'en plus vous nous glisser sa
part derrière
pourquoi plafonné ça vous blague vous
plafonné si vous ne pas être plafonnée
pas la part des dividendes dans e
le pib mais en revanche la part des
retraités vous allez la plafonner
pourquoi c'est le premier point
deuxième point pourquoi vous car
calculée sur la totalité la carrière et
non pas sur les 25 meilleures années
ça n'est pas lié à la retraite à points
c'est un deuxième truc que nous glisse
vous nous glisser par en dessous et
troisième chose surtout un mode de
calcul qui est complètement
incompréhensible a donc je lis une
retraite d'un montant égal au produit de
l'ensemble des points ce cas son compte
personnel de carrière à la date d'effet
de sa retraite par la valeur de service
du point fixé à cette date et ensuite
chacun de ces taux doit être supérieur à
zéro est compris entre l'évolution
annuelle des prix hors tabac l évolution
annuelle du café furie fans et aussi de
suite il
il en est à une minute 15 s'il a le
droit de s'exprimer comme lui chacun
d'entre nous laissez les s'exprimer
apparemment une minute 15e rue france
c'est déjà trop pour l'un pour la
majorité jeu on a là monsieur turquois
il était présent lors du débat qu'on a
eue sur les états généraux de
l'alimentation
je lui ai dit au moment où il ya eu ce
set cette loi sur l'agriculture
vous mettez en place d'une usine à gaz
incompréhensible et qui fera l'est le
jeu des distributeurs je n'ai cessé de
leurs appels répétés ici on m'a dit mais
non c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer tout ça on voit aujourd'hui à la
fin de la foire on voit qui est le
gagnant
aujourd'hui le gagnant sur les états
généraux l'alimentation c'est la grande
distribution et je vous le dis de la
même manière ici on pourra le vérifier
mais vous serez plus sur ces bancs
depuis très longtemps on pourra vérifier
ici seul qui soit à quoi tu conduiras
pas seulement la retraite à points mais
ce que vous nous passez par tous avec la
retraite à points eh bien ça va conduire
oui à la baisse des pensions et merci
monsieur
rue faire monsieur aviragnet alors vous
nous dit on ne va pas baisser les
retraites globalement côté quand on
calcule sur l'ensemble de la carrière
c'est toujours plus défavorable que sur
les cinq meilleures années
c'est comme les notes de l'élève sur une
année scolaire c'est exactement le même
calcul
alors après fait on vous dit mais
comment voulez vous qu'on vous croire
c'est ce que vous faites des bus depuis
le début de ce mandat vous avez tous
baissé toutes les prestations sociales
l'apl les prestations sociales les
retraites les seuls que vous n'avez pas
baissé
c'est les grandes fortunes la taxe la
cetera alors actionné a sonné s'est
conclue c'est que vous êtes des libéraux
et et arrêter de dormir tout le monde
merci monsieur aviragnet je vais vous
demander à chacun de vous calmer
chacun de vous calmer voilà allez nous
allons voter sur le sel 726 ya pas de
demandeurs je suis déçu n'y pas de
demandes de scrutins publics donc c'est
à main levée que les choses vont se
faire un avis défavorable de monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté nous en venons et bien
évidemment un autre amendement sur
lequel le 26
775 je suis surpris mais saisie d'une
demande de scrutin public par vous
monsieur brunel donc il est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée et je vous
donne la parole
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
vous poser plusieurs questions donc
effectivement ce système que vous
proposez chacun devient comptable de son
seul sort et les droits à la retraite
réplique les difficultés vécues pendant
la carrière professionnelle sans
correction y compris à travers les
prétendus dispositif solidarité à ce
propos je voudrais savoir puisque je les
lui vous allez me confirmer ou me
contredire que le chômage non indemnisé
ne sera plus pris en compte dans le
droit à la retraite alors que le système
actuel permet de valider jusqu'à six
trimestres au moment de la première
inscription à pôle emploi ce qui
aujourd'hui bénéfique aux jeunes qui
rentrent sur le marché du travail
rappelons en outre que les trimestre
peuvent aujourd'hui être accordée
lorsque la période du chômage non
indemnisé suit une période de chômage
indemnisé à hauteur de 4 trimestre pour
les moins de 55 ans ou de vin trimestre
pour les plus de 55 ans alors le chômage
indemnisé en ce qui concerne votre
réforme ne sera pris en compte que sur
la base allocations versées quand le
système actuel permet lui d'acquérir des
trimestre votre nouveau système sera
donc très pénalisant si vous confirmez
ce que je dis dès lors que l'on prend en
compte la callas complète les maigres
points cumulés en période de chômage
auront donc une incidence négative sur
le montant des pensions alors
qu'aujourd'hui le calcul sur les 25
meilleures années neutralise les
périodes d'interruption d'activité à
volontaires merci monsieur brunel
monsieur rapporteur
merci monsieur le président les articles
sur les solidarités la prise en compte
du chômage sont plus plus en avant dans
le texte
là vous nous proposez à l'alinéa de
substituer aux mots point le mot
trimestre donc c'est pas vraiment
l'objet de l'amendement donc je veux
bien qu'on en fasse tout à chaque fois
mais je on le verra mais co-rapporteur
seront plus à même d'expliquer les choix
qui ont été retenus monsieur monsieur
rufin je vous mets au défi de trouver
dans le texte
comme quoi on plafonne le pib à 14% pour
les retraites vous ne le trouverez vous
ne le trouverez et on en reparlera donc
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les députés
monsieur le député brunel j'entends que
vous vouliez parler du chômage
là vous savez qu'on va pouvoir le faire
dans le titre iii b juste comme se
redire les choses le système actuel pour
le chômage sont des trimestres avec des
salaires porto coûte à zéro donc vous
c'est toujours les affaires de cette
fameuse trimestre dont vous me parlez
mais moi moi je pense que on peut
distribuer beaucoup de trimestre dans la
mesure où ça aucun impact puisque c'est
trimestre n'amène aucun salaire portés
aux comptes
alors la réalité c'est que les périodes
de chômage d'ailleurs quand on vous dit
écoutez le système actuel les 25
meilleures années salies ce genre de
soucis là bas ça n'existe pas du tout
d'autant plus que vous m'avez expliqué à
de nombreuses reprises depuis quinze
jours qu'il y avait beaucoup de chômage
au sens quand on était passé 55 ans donc
ça veut dire bien et si on refait le
lien avec ce qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure avec le président exerce où on
s'était dit qu'il valait mieux avoir les
25 dernières années comme étant les 25
meilleurs donc ça veut dire que pour
tous ceux dont vous venez d'actes et
vous même que pour tous ceux qui sont
que vous je rentre que vous défendiez
d'ailleurs un qui sont malheureusement
au chômage entre 55 et 62 63 eh bien ça
va être très difficile pour eux dans le
calcul leurs pensions actuels puisqu'ils
vont avoir des salaires qui vont être
portés aux comptes à zéro et que les
salaires dit 25 meilleures années envers
on a des périodes bien au delà des 25
dernières années sur lequel ils auront
subi une décapitalisation significative
depuis l'arrêt indexation sur
l'inflation et les salaires
vous voyez je pense qu'il faut faire
très attention sur ses prises de
position parce que j'entends votre photo
vous voulez vraiment être dans une
démarche de solidarité vous voulez être
vigilant sur ce tome est haut en fin de
compte votre proposition arrivera
exactement inverse donc j'ai envie de
dire retirer votre amendement voté avec
nous cette grande évolution sociale
qu'on vous propose qui permettra
justement à ceux qui sont victimes
d'accidents de la vie est chômage
d'avoir un regard sur leur carrière qui
soit complet au travers ma propre tous
merci monsieur ministre madame lecoq
tous les revenir sur ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure puisque on veut nous
donner systématiquement l'image des
méchants libéraux qui n'ont pas de coeur
et qui ont soit disant baisser les
prestations sociales j'en ai rappelé
d'abord que c'est totalement faux que
nous avons augmenté le minimum
vieillesse que nous avons augmenté
l'allocation adulte handicapé donc déjà
peut-être rectifier un peu le tir par
rapport à ce qui a été dit et dire aussi
que sur ce régime universel des
retraites
nous attribuons et moi j'en suis très
fier des points de solidarité pour les
incidents de parcours qui peuvent être
vécues par nos concitoyens que chacun
d'entre nous peut vivre que ce soit du
chômage que ce soit une période de
maladie ou une période d'invalidité et
ces périodes là vont être prises en
compte et permettre l'attribution de
points de solidarité nous avons pu dans
nos différents ateliers citoyens ont
constaté que c'était aussi une attente
de nos concitoyens et que c'est une
façon de pérenniser aussi notre contrat
social dans ce nouveau système de
retraites que nous mettons en place
merci merci monsieur rifains
et madame le sien allô oui merci
monsieur le président bon je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on se comprenne parfaitement mais
ce que j'ai bien écouté la réponse du
ministre mais j'ai pas été totalement
convaincu parce que ce que l'on explique
à travers l'amendement qui a défendu
alain bruneel c'est que aujourd'hui les
trimestre accumuler c'est le trimestre a
cumulé qui vous permettent d'être
éligibles à la retraite et c'est les 25
meilleures années où les six derniers
mois qui vous fixent la pension quand
vous êtes au chômage non indemnisé que
vous êtes un jeune qui est rentré sur le
marché du travail vous avez si trimestre
non indemnisés qui compte dans les
trimestres cumulables pour obtenir la
retraite c'est quatre trimestres de
chômage non indemnisé après une période
de chômage indemnisé quand on a moins de
55 ans et ça peut être 20 trimestres de
chômage non indemnisé qui suit une
période de chômage indemnisé pour ceux
qui ont plus de 55 ans tout ça forme d
trimestre qui cumulait vous permettre
d'obtenir le nombre de trimestres pour
partir à la retraite mais la pension
elle même elle est calculée sur les 25
meilleures années où les six derniers
mois et donc ses 25 meilleures années où
les six derniers mois
neutralisent financièrement les périodes
de chômage non indemnisé mais par contre
elle compte dans l'accumulation des
trimestres nécessaires pour avoir le
droit à la retraite ce qui nous inquiète
ii faut pas y voir malice qui nous
inquiète très légitimement c'est qu'à
partir du moment où on prend toute la
carrière y compris
les périodes de chômage c'est que
mécaniquement on fasse baisser baisser
les pensions et que par ailleurs pour
les jeunes qui rentrent sur le marché du
travail et qui sont au chômage non
indemnisé aujourd'hui ça content
trimestre demain ce ne sera pas cumuler
dans le nombre de points nécessaires
pour obtenir votre retraite donc il ya
bien un risque tout cas c'est notre
lecture mais peu un risque de préjudice
pour les périodes de chômage non
indemnisé quel que soit d'ailleurs l'âge
auquel on les submersibles monsieur le
député monsieur petit oui monsieur
richard vous avez commencé par dire que
vous alliez continuer à dire d'abord si
vous pouviez continuer à ne pas crier à
dire mais moi je suis pas ici pour dire
et pour répéter je suis ici pour
débattre donc je vais essayer de conques
de vous convaincre
il n'y a pas de pourcentage du pib dans
la loi comment si vous voulez trouver un
chemin mathématiques dans ce que nous
disons dans la loi c 28 %
c'est les cotisations je vous rappelle
que nous ramenons 97 % des revenus où
ils ne sont que 60 aujourd'hui
nous ramenons 97 % des revenus dans la
répartition obligatoires ok x 28 % et
après vous pouvez calculer quelle sera
la part qui est très évolutif vous avez
les chiffres dans les chiffres du cor
quelle sera la part du travail dans le
pib
et là vous aurez quelque chose qui
approchera non pas quelque chose qui est
plafonné mais quelque chose qui sera
constatée après je suis désolé il faut
sortir parce que le système à points
fait sortir de ce que j'appellerais
votre logique assurantielle c'est une
logique assurantielle cumulé que vous
faites si vous prenez des itinéraires
personnels et puis vous les additionner
ensemble mais il faut revenir à ce
qu'est la répartition la répartition
c'est une démarche qui commence par le
global c'est à dire quel est le montant
de cotisation qui rentrent le montant
pas le pourcentage de pub et c'est le
montant qui sera multiplié par quatre à
l'échéance le dos à laquelle nous
parlons le montant on a un montant en ce
montant n'est plus sur la table
je les ai beaucoup expliqué pendant que
vous étiez pas là monsieur rufin mais ce
montant n'est plus sur la table en
quarante deux paniers il est en un seul
panier sur la table commune et nous nos
divisions plus en fonction de chaque
petite histoire personnelle nous
divisons avec un mode qui correspond au
fait qu'il y à un panier unique mais le
global
c'est là que vous pouvez pas dire que ça
va baisser puisque le panier quatre fois
plus gros et le nombre de gens qui se le
partagent
si on passe même en intégrant ceux qui
n'ont pas de retraite aujourd'hui et les
retraites indique lui remet un subtil et
17 millions à 20 20 21 millions et en
même temps ça passe de 3 125 milliards
80 mètres voire donc le montant moyen
mais se revoir cet amendement non
monsieur reford vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
non mais vous êtes exprimés monsieur
rufin
bon d'accord je je pensais mais attendez
franchement un samedi après-midi
s'énerver parce que je me suis mépris et
je considérais que monsieur rufin
s'était déjà exprimée alors ce n'est pas
le cas bon tout à l'heure j'ai failli
donner la parole à madame la sphère
alors monsieur petit s'était exprimé
également donc ça arrive avec tous les
groupes
n'ayez aucune crainte monsieur rifains
pour mercy le supplément monsieur le
rapporteur me dit je vous mets au défi
de trouver dans le texte que c'est
plafonné à 14%
voici l'avis du conseil d'état le
conseil d'état constate que le projet a
pour objectif de stabiliser la dépenses
liées aux retraites à 14% du pib malgré
le nombre de personnes de plus de 65 ans
étant appelée à augmenter de 70% d'ici
2070 c'est la première chose dont l'avis
du conseil d'état où figure également un
tableau le tableau numéro 39 monsieur le
rapporteur effets de la réforme soit
dépenses de prestations à horizon 2050
et où on a en 2015 13,6 pour cent du pib
en 2030 13 5% du pib en 2040 13,3 pour
cent du pib en 2050
12 09 % du pib donc c'est bien monsieur
petit évidemment ça ne figure pas telle
quelle dans votre projet parce que vous
diriez pas ce que vous évidemment pas ce
que vous diriez franchement aux français
on va baisser les retraites on va
baisser la part des retraites et on veut
maintenant vous débrouillez vous passez
par axa et par blackrock vous
capitalisez vous liriez ça franchement
en france et il ne l'accepterai pas donc
qu'est-ce que vous faites à la place
vous le déguiser évidemment il ya
quelque chose à la base de tout ça nous
n'avons pas confiance en vous les
français n'ont pas confiance en vous
quand vous parlez justice sociale oui
nous n'avons pas confiance en vous on
peut pas avoir confiance en une majorité
qui parle de justice sociale quand les
grands marqueurs de son quinquennat ont
été la suppression lisf pour les plus
riches et où était oui oui et on était
là la désindexation des retraites pour
les peaux les retraités par exemple
oui oui
merci monsieur christophe mais arrêtez à
les mesures y stocke s'exprimer lui
c'est à parole sinon oui monsieur le
président sans le sens du spectacle
parce que j'ai pas besoin de vidéo pour
mettre en valeur mais seulement
seulement produire qu'effectivement on
est bien d'accord ce n'est donc pas
inscrit dans le texte juste rappeler
quand même qu' il serait bon aussi
d'aller voir l'estimation du corps ce
que le corps avec les mêmes hypothèses
de croissance que celles qui sont
proposées donc dans le nouveau système
prévoit bien également que la part des
retraites dans le pipe passerait de 14 %
à 12,9 donc là ce projet propose 14 à 12
8 excusez moi mais on est quasiment sur
la même trajectoire
deuxièmement c'est bien beau de parler
de pourcentage du pis mais faut-il
savoir ce qu'il advient du bib donc en
soit on peut aussi imaginer que au lieu
d'avoir une vision assez réductrice qui
est la vôtre dire voilà on va rester
constant qu'on est là aussi une autre
évolution qui permet de voir des jours
meilleurs et en aucun cas d'attester
votre continuum de dire que les pensions
vont baisser
merci alors maintenant ah oui monsieur
rapportant désolé monsieur enfin moi je
m'exprimerai pas sur sur le fond et sur
le fond de vos convictions qui sont les
vôtres
mais je vous demanderez vous étiez
peut-être pas là quand je les dis il
faut il faut en tant que rapporteur que
je sois présent tous les jours toute la
durée du site
là vous arrivez et pour affirmer vos
arguments vous criez c'est vraiment mais
je vous assure milieu difficile
physiquement à entendre en permanence
exprimez vous vous c'est votre droit le
plus le plus profond mais exprime le en
simplement en adaptant le volume sonore
pour qu' on puisse et comprendre et
partager votre c'est votre argumentaire
je le conteste pas mais soyons je vous
assure qu'il ya une fatigue qui
s'accumule et pardon mais non monsieur
ban ali si ce jeu je vous invite à ce qu
on ait des débats plus poser de ce point
de vue là pas vous-même lasserre vous
êtes vous aussi un
oh bah oui excusez moi mais c'est le
président woerth fait juste jeux
présents sur ce débat c'est vrai que
vous avez vous indiquez clairement dans
l'étude d'impact que la part des
retraites dans le pays va plutôt baisser
d'ici les 30 ans qui viennent
ça veut dire que le niveau de vie moyen
des retraités augmentera moins vite que
le niveau de vie moyen global c'est
probablement cela que cela veut dire
après c'est un choix
on verra dans 30 ans remarqué on verra
dans 30 ans mais c'est aussi un choix
moi je pense que les retraités font
entièrement partie de la nation et de la
nation économique et dire qu'il il
contribue à l'augmentation de la
richesse d'une autre manière que pour
les actifs évidemment mais ils
contribuent à cette augmentation de la
richesse nationale et il me semblerait
naturel même si dans le passé ça pas pu
être fait puisque c'était uniquement à
des que c'est sur l'inflation
mais le sommet mais vous allez continuer
à indexer le prix d'achat du point sur
la valeur du solaire et la valeur et la
valeur et la valeur de service du point
sur sur l'inflation dont surface en tout
cas le contraire pardon donc en tout cas
vous aller décrocher le contraire vous
avez décroché
vous avez décroché la valeur de la
retraite par rapport au prix de la
retraite
vous allez le faire au moins jusqu'en
2045 et puis après vous verrez bien donc
on a cette idée que les retraités
participerez - à la création de richesse
que les actifs easy participent
autrement et je pense que c'est très
important de pouvoir le dire et c'est
parce que disent vos graphiques
merci voilà nous allons pouvoir procéder
au vote sur cet amendement scrutin
public
bon le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat de ce scrutin votants 75
exprimé 75 majorité 38 pour 4 contre 71
nous allons passer à l'amendement
suivant qui va nous être présentés je ne
suis pas par qui le chef 1756 par
monsieur bernalicis mais indique que le
groupe la france a soumises a demandé un
scrutin public sur cet amendement et
donc qu'il est annoncé dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée monsieur berlin 6 merci
messieurs le prison j'entends ça va
ralentir les débats mais non parce que
tu as publique est annoncée avant tout
le monde pourrait gagner son siège ça
prend 10 secondes d'appuyer sur le
bouton et que vous inquiétez pas chers
collègues tout va bien se passer
tout va bien se passer c'est pas la
peine de me crier sur le côté comme ça
merci monsieur le président de me donner
la parole pour rebondir sur
l'intervention du président woerth à
l'instant il ya une question quand même
qui est importante sur comment va
évoluer comment vous comptez faire
évoluer la valeur d'acquisition du point
et la valeur de service
quand on vous écoute on a l'impression
que ces deux courbes qui suive la même
trajectoire
mais quand on regarde les objectifs
poursuivis et le fait que la part dans
le pib diminue c'est bien qu'ils aient
une décorrélation et vous n'allez pas
indexé de la même manière la valeur
d'acquisition du point et la valeur de
service
on aimerait en avoir la certitude quant
aux collectes petit qui nous rabâche que
bientôt il y aura 400 milliards oui bah
oui parce que le pib augmente chaque
année et donc finalement la somme de
milliards augmentent elles aussi
sauf que le coût de la vie augmente lui
aussi c'est tout le principe de
l'inflation de mutation du pbx et enfin
ça c'est dans un monde pur et parfait
avec des courbes qui progresse
tranquillement
rien ne dit qu'on n'aura pas une
prochaine crise financière
moi je la prédisaient pour avant 2022
finalement elle sera peut-être corrélés
pour le coup avec l'épidémie du
coronavirus qui bouleverse l'économie
mondiale
donc vos projections ça montre bien que
elles ne tiennent pas debout et qu'il y
à un risque très fort en fonction de
variations économiques intempestives
qu'il y ait des pertes très importantes
pour les futurs retraités qui n'auront
aucune certitude quant à la valeur de
leur retraite
voilà donc c'est pourquoi nous
continuons à vous dire nous nous sommes
opposés à votre système par points et
nous sommes opposés à votre système de
retraite par points dits universels
parce que même s'ils ne se gagnent juste
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président la
suppression de l'alinéa 5 qu'on consiste
à supprimer le côté contributif des des
cotisations pour pour acquérir un
certain nombre de points donc c'est
vraiment le coeur de notre système donc
s'ils seraient défavorables sur sur le
fond et puis vous avez vous avez raison
de dire qu'une crise mondiale peut
secouer le système et en mutualisant
d'abord en adoptant en confirmant lusage
d'un système par répartition où elle les
les cotisations de chaque année assurent
les pensions de chaque année on est
beaucoup plus résilient qu'un système
par capitalisation donc je vous confirme
contrairement à ce que vous dites qu'on
n'a aucune intention développer un
système par capitalisation d'ailleurs
non mais c'est vrai attendez on n'est
pas obligé de crier
monsieur le rapporteur à la parole et on
l'écouté
voilà c'est tout lesieu rufin cpc mais
c'est lamentable et qui sera maître à
danser vrai sur tous les bancs sont tous
des cas mais voilà maintenant donc le le
côté le côté mutualisation et le côté
qui élargit la répartition par rapport
en termes de proportion de revenus par
rapport à actuellement donc renforce
cette solidarité
et puis qui dit mutualisation coque
actuellement on est organisé par bach
régime donne aussi plus de solidité s'il
ya une profession qui était plus impacté
que les autres je prends souvent mon
exemple des agriculteurs il ya eu un
moment donné une crise importante sur
les prix des matières premières
agricoles ya quelques années et du coup
les ressources les ressources de la msa
ont été profondément impactés par cette
crise et canton mutualisent on atténue
on ne limite pas parce que la crise à la
lieu mais on atténue les conséquences de
cette crise et on est plus fort quand on
est plus solidaire c'est l'objectif de
cette réforme allait falloir monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président je ferais
relativement sobre pour ces amendements
de suppression de l'alinéa rapporteur
s'est exprimée vite et favorablement
merci monsieur le ministre alors j'ai
comme demande de parole d'abord monsieur
bothorel merci monsieur le président et
les bravos pour l'organisation des
débats alors je sais que vous étiez
attendu tire une un événement important
chez vous et vous le faites avec
beaucoup de lancer mon côté un peu jean
lassalle parfois ça peut m'arriver c'est
en ce lieu mythique elle dans ce billet
je pense que du côté de la somme en est
fière de vous aujourd'hui non plus
sérieusement il ya un truc que j'arrive
pas à comprendre c'est que je une fois
les débats terminer ici je regarde la
télé les informations et de ce côté-là
de lumicycles depuis des semaines on
vous répète que l'étude d'impact est
truqué que l'étude l'impact n'est en
rien quelque chose de solide
or depuis quelques jours à l'appui d'un
certain nombre de vos amendements vous
citer des passages de lisieux de
l'impact j'aimerais juste comprendre
comment la côte est elle est truqué et à
jeter et comment vous l'a convoqué ici
au moins pour de retrouver un peu de
sérénité intellectuelle merci monsieur
bothorel deux fois merci monsieur mattei
oui merci monsieur le président je peux
que me féliciter cet ex excellence
présidence également voilà mais ça
devient suspect ça peut devenir si ce
club mais bon c'est ça ne m'étonne pas
ça ne m'étonne pas le plus sérieusement
je me suis absenté hier après midi et ce
matin bien que j'ai essayé de se suivre
les débats je crois que la méthode n'a
pas changé on est toujours sur la
suppression des alinéas les uns à la
suite des autres moi je prouve que que
c'est très fort je les dis bhl et
plusieurs fois est bonne et que
justement ce sujet des comptes
personnels par rapport aux points
et cette méthode d'acquisition est une
bonne méthode qui permet d'avoir une
visibilité qui est même une méthode
moderne et quand je vous entends j'ai
l'impression d'entendre des gens un
petit peu je sais pas chagrin inquiet je
voudrais pas que vous n'êtes pas dans la
modernité
excusez moi vous n'êtes pas dans la
modernité je pense que c'est un système
assez moderne qu'on nous propose qui
existe déjà mais qui est un bel outil
en plus moi ce que j'aimerais bien
encore une fois c'est qu'on parle des
sujets chaque fois qu'on parle du texte
et là monsieur le représentant d'un
france a soumises
vous évoquez les méthodes d'acquisition
des points c'est l'article 9 encore une
fois donc si on pouvait revenir au débat
mais j'insiste nous sommes sur un
système moderne et lisible pour les
jeunes et je crois qu'ils nous qui nous
entendent et alors j'ai un sentiment
j'interroge beaucoup les jeunes
actuellement par rapport à la retraite
et le débat permet de dire parce que
beaucoup me disent et pensent qu'on
n'aura pas de retraite nous est là avec
ce débat ils ont l'impression qu'ils
auront une retraite et ça je crois que
c'est un point positif
merci monsieur mattei jeu pourra
contrevenants pâte procéder au vote
oui mais non mais si vous le faites
monsieur rifains je vous donne ma parole
mais il joue voilà ça va être ça sert
mais effectivement malgré cette
difficulté à voir à 180 degrés je m'en
veux moi aussi saluer votre présidence e
books lorsque vous êtes venus j'aurais
pu le dire d'ailleurs à ce moment là
voilà monsieur rapporteur vous m'avez
mis au défi le défi est relevé puisque
sa figure à l'intérieur de l'avis du
conseil d'état et à l'intérieur de votre
étude d'impact je sais pas combien bien
de coups je gagne à la buvette
mais quand même le défi à relever c'est
la première chose ensuite j'entends vous
crier trop fort je suis ce que je suis
mon éducation politique je n'ai pas fait
dans les bureaux feutrés et donc en
effet je la porte ici je la porte ici et
génisses et je pense que ça n'est pas
mauvais pour vous ça n'est pas mauvais
pour vous d'avoir un influent mais de ce
que pourrait être l'odeur le bruit et
l'odeur de du pays réel dehors quand
vous rentrerez dans vos circonscriptions
avec l'immense toute satisfaction que va
donner votre réforme des retraites
je viens vous apporter un avant goût et
je pense que vous devriez me remercier
c'est la première chose ensuite sur le
raisonnement de monsieur petit sur dire
voilà il va ailleurs une multiplication
par quatre du pib depuis 40 ans depuis
que je suis née j'entends dans le ventre
de ma mère
de nos jours on l'entendait déjà en 1975
croissance croissance croissance
croissance qui allait nous apporter le
bonheur l'emploi la prospérité et
maintenant c'est sur cette croissance
exponentielle que viendra s'appuyer eu
nos retraites
eh bien ça ne nous rassure pas ça ne me
rassure pas pour nos retraites et ça ne
me rassure pas plat pour la planète
ça ne me rassure pas pour nos retraites
parce que c'est faire une projection sur
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
inconnu
on n'a pas la garantie la voir ce taux
de croissance continuelle qui viendra
nous faire prospérer à l'avenir c'est la
première fois la deuxième chose c'est
que je ne le souhaite pas aujourd'hui le
gâteau qu'on a est déjà un gâteau pourri
la solution n'est pas de le faire
grossir grossir grossir et encore
grossir vous ça n'est pas compatible
avec l'exigence environnementale
nous devons y renoncer pour des
exigences environnementales
ce qui ce qui est important je réussis
la répartition du gâteau à la nous
allons maintenant procéder au vote sur
cet amendement
le cese 756 il ya une demande de scrutin
public
si bien que chacun regagne sa place sur
les ailes j'attends vous n'êtes pas très
loin alors je me vois donc ce cet
amendement le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultats résultat du scrutin en votant
71 expriment et 70 majorité 36 pour 4
contre 66 monsieur ben ali si c'est un
rappel au règlement d'accord a eu le
droit vous propose cinq minutes
allez la séance et reprises
monsieur monsieur poche vous avez
l'amendement 26 7 166 oui merci monsieur
le président alors que je tout à l'heure
monsieur mattei disait le mode de calcul
du point ça viendra après mais enfin
dans l'alinéa 5 de l'article présent on
évoque quand même les modalités
d'acquisition des points et c'est sur
cet alinéa que porte notre amendement
puisque vous nous proposez en fait si
j'ai bien compris le calcul du point il
faudra diviser le montant de la
cotisation payée par la valeur
d'acquisition du point pour obtenir le
nombre de points inscrits au compte
personnel on voit donc apparaître un
nouvel outil qui est celui de la valeur
d'acquisition elle est centrale car
cette valeur détermine le nombre de
points que le salarié obtient et donc in
fine et son refrain mais sur cette
valeur sa retraite sur cette valeur
nous nous avons une fois de plus aucune
information le rapport de le voit parler
de 10 euros mais la loi elles celles
qu'on examine actuellement elle ne dit
rien ne fixons rien et donc c'est une
absence préjudiciable
c'est pas la seule absence de cette
réforme mais a beaucoup de trous dans
cette réforme on l'a on l'a dit mais ça
c'est quand même un trou majeur celui de
la valeur du point est le problème qui
se pose est évident si la valeur
d'acquisition du poids augmente il
faudra pour une même la conséquence sera
que pour un même montant de cotisation
on aura moins de points et donc il
faudra augmenter
le travail les heures supplémentaires la
durée de travail ou la durée au travail
pour obtenir le nombre de points
nécessaires donc on voit bien que ce
système et notamment avec tous les
manques et les trous qui existe
actuellement dans le la loi qui nous est
présenté est absolument pas rassurante
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
pensons qu'il est beaucoup plus sécure
de rester sur un système tout en
l'améliorant bien évidemment sur un
système de trimestre et d'annuités merci
merci monsieur peu monsieur le
rapporteur
concernant la suprématie de monsieur
président concernant le point et
trimestre je vais pas y revenir je
l'expliqué en début d'article 8 où nous
on considère que le système du point est
un outil de valorisation plus fin que le
trimestre
tu trimes sc trimestre et valeurs
portées au contre et qu' un certain
nombre de trimestre qui certes sont
comptabilisés été comptabilisés en tant
que durée mais n'ont pas forcément de
valeur aux comptes
et puis je voudrais revenir sur la
remarque faite précédemment par notre
collègue
moi non plus je n'ai pas été élevé dans
un bureau feutré
par contre ce qu'on m'a expliqué c'est
que le travail c'est dans la durée c'est
pas un c'est pas ponctuellement qu'on
intervient et puis ça ça s'appelle tout
simplement une politesse dans les
échanges et on peut avoir des positions
extrêmement différentes si je ne le
conteste pas mais on peut les exprimer
de façon de façon plus respectueuse les
uns des autres voilà ce que je tenais à
préciser des savoirs merci monsieur
important monsieur ministre
ainsi monsieur le président je cherche
essayez de de partager le voir qu'elle
pouvait être l'inquiétude de monsieur
députés un peu sur ce sujet et en fait
ce que vous soulignez c'est que la
valeur d'acquisition d'achat du point
à progresser on l'a dit de la même façon
que la valeur du service et donc ça veut
dire que même si un point coûte plus
cher ou un peu plus cher trois ans
quatre ans plus tard à l'achat il vaudra
aussi un peu plus cher puisque sa valeur
de service aura également au comté et
comme nos cotisations ce qui s'exprime
en pourcentage de notre salaire même si
on a un salaire qui est relativement bas
au modeste mais qu'il a au moins la
dynamique du smic
l'appelation on aura ces progressions
sachant que nos valeurs de service et
d'achat sont minimes à celle de
l'inflation et progression jusqu'en 2045
sur la base du revenu moyen d'activités
par tête d'eau pour faire court et
essayer de pas trop compliqué la valeur
du point à l'achat va augmenter mais ça
va leur offrir en service va augmenter
de la même façon un point vaudra un peu
plus cher mais donnera aussi un peu plus
aux droits humains proportion des faux
bond merci mesdames d'allos vous n'allez
pas demander la parole le président j'ai
repris des éléments de de l'article très
intéressant que vous découvrirez demain
de jean pisani ferry
ça vous dit quelque chose le programme
de votre candidat de l'époque et du
président de la république s'est
largement inspiré des travaux de jean
pisani-ferry il dit pour la grande
majorité des actifs et particulièrement
pour les plus jeunes la question la plus
lourde en matière de retraite est de
savoir sur quel niveau de pension ils
vont pouvoir compter demain c'est la
vraie question que nous débattons depuis
maintenant 2 13 jours celle inverse de
votre réponse dans cette réforme c'est
lui qui l'écrit vous n'avez réussi qu'à
attirer les angoisses qu'attiser les
angoisses en régime par répartition est
un contrat par lequel les actifs
investis ce collectivement dans les
performances économiques futurs du pays
au lieu d'acheter des titres financiers
effectivement à
personnel il acquiert collectivement des
droits sur la croissance à venir
l'objet des règles de la répartition est
de définir avec précision ses droits
mais le texte en discussion au parlement
reste elliptique sur plusieurs points
importants et notamment parce que
l'indexation ne sera complète
quand 2045 c'est pas moi qui le dit je
viens de vous lire l'extrait de
l'article qui sortira demain en 2045
c'est ça c'est cette période
d'incertitude de 25 ans qu'il faut que
vous entendiez merci monsieur bernalicis
merci monsieur prison deux points le
premier point c'est que j'aimerais
vraiment comprendre quelles sont les
intentions du ministre et du
gouvernement par de la même le la
discussion du futur conseil national des
retraites sur l'évolution de la valeur
d'achat d'acquisition du point et la
valeur de service vous dit l'une va
monter l'autre si et du coup ok
peut-être que la valeur d'achat du point
va augmenter mais de façon la valeur de
service aussi sauf que la valeur d'achat
du point
c'est au moment où vous cotisez donc
c'est chaque année pendant 40 ans 41 ans
42 enfin bon peu importe en fonction de
votre parcours
la valeur de service et c'est du one
shot cessé au moment où vous liquidez
votre vote votre retraite
mais si pendant 40 ans la valeur
d'acquisition a été plus forte que
l'évolution de la valeur de service vous
retrouvez à avoir acheté vos points
chers et à les vendre moins cher c'est
une probabilité parce que rien ne
prévoit dans votre texte que les deux
soient soit corrélé ou alors ou alors
j'ai mal lu et vous allez m'expliquer le
contraire et puis deuxième chose je
tiens à préciser quand même au ministre
rapporteur et aux collègues que nous
avons fait l'effort dans notre groupe de
toutes et tous les 17 s'intéresser sur
le fond du sujet sur le fond du texte et
sur le fond des 65 article on se relaie
tous les groupes se relaient pour tenir
sept jours durant sept jours sur sept et
les horaires qui vont avec
il ya des groupes où on se relaie où
tout le monde prend la parole et ya
d'autres groupes où on se relaie et on
n'entend pas ce qu'il suive que
ponctuellement le texte moi je préférais
entendre 100% des collègues sur les
bancs
parce que tout le monde aura à voter
cette loi donc oui je suis fier qu'on se
relaient et qu'on soit là ponctuellement
sur tel ou tel article
je voulais le dire parce que ça n'enlève
rien à la valeur de nos arguments et à
nos valeurs individuelles
merci jeu mais on voit cet amendement
avis défavorable de monsieur le ministre
est de monsieur le rapporteur qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est résulté amendement donnant lieu à
des sous-amendements le 25 55 d'abord
des amendements identiques alors le 25
55 me suis aviragnet oui merci monsieur
le président demande des femmes cet
amendement juste peut-être une petite
précision tout à l'heure il ya une toute
une confrontation sur la part du pib
dans le texte
simplement faire remarquer dans le
prolongement ce que j'avais dit en début
avant l'article 8 où je parlais de
manque de précision et de flou dans tout
ce texte il extrêmement compliqué de
travailler sur des éléments qui manquent
à tous les niveaux parce que je
regardais rien dans ce texte sur les
variables importe importante du projet
de loi qui n'y sont pas davantage que la
part du pib ou sauna le texte l'âge
pivot le taux de la décote la valeur
d'acquisition du point la valeur de
service dont je trouve que c'est
extrêmement compliqué de travailler on
est vraiment dans une impasse
je vois pas comment on peut aller plus
loin avec tous ces éléments qui manquent
et qui nous met dans une situation
extrêmement compliquée pour pouvoir
avancer et travailler sérieusement et de
manière profitable
alors pour en revenir à cet amendement
il vise à s'assurer que toute heure
travaillée donne lieu aux mêmes droits
matière d'acquisition de points sans
considération de temps de travail annuel
encore une précision qui est semble-t-il
manque en tout cas qu'on perçoit comme
tel le système actuel repose sur la
notion de temps de travail et correspond
à un mois de salaire etc avaient des
incidences sur la compacte stabilisation
des trimestres et donc du niveau de la
pension et doit afin de lever toute
ambiguïté quant à cette question de la
valeur des points en fonction du nombre
d'heures
vas y est quant à la définition d'une
carrière complète dans un régime par
points
le présent amendement propose donc de
préciser encore une fois une précision
que tout est retravaillé donna lieu au
versement des cotisations ouvre les
mêmes droits indépendamment du nombre
d'heures travaillées dans l'année le
référentiel annuel est en retenue pour
se calquer sur la temporalité de la
calcul du poète je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député le 24
654 n'est pas défendu le cas en 2 605
monsieur monsieur peut il et chasse aux
amendements défendus
j'imagine pareil pour le cas en 2 604
mais je vérifie que je n'ai pas d'autres
c'est bon monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président e d'abord
peut-être pour répondre à monsieur habib
régné sur les éléments qu'il faut
prendre en compte dans le système actuel
dans le système proposé dans cette
réforme
vous avez une valeur d'acquisition pour
le point une valeur de liquidation et on
verra l'une et l'autre peuvent évoluer
de base de la même façon ou légèrement
différemment en fonction du de la
décision du conseil d'administration de
la caisse nationale donc valeur
d'acquisition valeurs de service vous
avez un âge déquilibre c'est une 4 une
troisième une troisième
variable mais qui s'applique à tout le
monde aujourd'hui je vous invite à faire
un inventaire exhaustif des variables
qui existent régime par régime
elles sont pas les mêmes donc je vous
mesurez par 42 régime alors c'est ça
serait faux de dire par 42 régime parce
que y en a certains qui partagent des
éléments communs mais je vous assure que
quand vous avez ces trois quatre
variables cc3 quatre instruments de
pilotage à la main de la seine et rue
pour gérer au mieux le système et tenir
compte des évolutions démographiques des
évolutions économiques
je trouvais intéressante monsieur
bernalicis vote et je ne vois pas de
malice à votre présentation mais dans
votre réflexion vous estimiez
aujourd'hui on va acquérir des points
imaginons que le système soit en place
d'ores et déjà va acquérir des points
et alors comment on va avoir un
rendement les points vont valoir moins
cher dans 40 ans mais le rendement qu'on
fait aujourd'hui dans dans dans le dans
l'étude dans le rapport de monsieur
delevoye avait été fixé 10 euros en
valeur d'acquisition et 55 centimes en
valeur de liquidation
mais comme on est un système par
répartition c'est bien les cotisations
d'aujourd'hui donc les points acquis
aujourd'hui et les pensions servies
aujourd'hui c'est c'est pas votre propre
c'est pas votre propre retraite c'est
pas comme un système par capitalisation
où on regarderait le capital qu'on amis
et on voudrait avoir un taux de
rendement sur le capital qu'on a mis là
on acquiert des droits mais des droits
qui seront valorisés en fonction de ce
que sera l'equilibre pension actif un
actif et pensions le ratio dans 40 ans
ici on est en début de carrière ou dans
vingt ans sur nos milieux de terrain et
c'est donc ne réfléchissons pas comme un
placement à titre personnel voyons le
comme une somme cotisée chaque année et
comme une somme distribuée chaque année
en termes de valeur les 5 5% évoqués
sont le rapport entre la valeur du point
à qui chaque année est la valeur du
point
servis chaque année
ensuite sur l'indexation sur
l'indexation c'est madame dalloz je
crois qu'il parlait de jean pisani ferry
qui dit ainsi que dans 20 ans le les 25
ans c'est dans 25 ans mais on vous dit
que depuis depuis 2000 25 ou depuis
aujourd'hui jusqu'en 2045 un minima en
passe de l'évolution suivant l'inflation
qui est celle actuelle à l'évolution
suivant les revenus donc on va en
croissant donc c'est mieux plus
dynamique et progressivement faut qu'on
passe d'un système indexé d'une façon
mais comme le minimum c'est l'inflation
au minimum on est sur le système actuel
est au maximum on est sur un système qui
est plus dynamique
c'est entre les deux à la main de la cnr
hui pour pour passer d'un mode de
déplacement à un autre finalement c est
et comment on fait cette transition
il se donne le temps si la ceni rue veut
le faire plus rapidement parce que elle
en maîtrise l'ensemble des paramètres et
pourra le faire plus rapidement mais
vous allez avoir des gens qui vont dans
les 20 ans qui viennent vont ils rentrer
progressivement le système général des
2027 ou 2025 et un certain nombre
d'autres professions qui relève des
régimes spéciaux plus tard donc il faut
laisser la main à la scène est rude pour
utiliser les outils qui sont à sa
disposition pour régler le plus finement
possible cette intégration des femmes
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le député je crois
que le rapporteur vous a répondu à ces
complètement sur ce sujet votre question
elle est portée sur la quotité annuelle
de travail et en fait je crois que nous
avons pu aborder à plusieurs reprises le
sujet de la façon dont nous allions
comptabiliser la durée la durée il
n'aura de sens que dans des cas tout à
fait particulier comme celle notamment
du minimum contributif voilà et donc ton
ce cadre là la notion de durée bien sûr
sera reconstituée comme je lai
d'ailleurs déjà décrit au travers d'une
recherche de diluer l'équivalent de 600
heures smic de cotisations sur une année
si c'est le cas
l'année sera entièrement validée même si
il n'y a eu que quelques mois de travail
et mes quelques mois à temps plein ou
peuvent faire 600 heures smic sur
l'année si ce n'était pas le cas on ira
voir dans l'année le nombre de mois sur
lesquelles il y a eu à minima 50 heures
donc voilà la réponse parce que c'est
essentiellement pour le minimum de
pension que cela aura l'intérêt
maintenant si vous n'êtes pas concerné
merle minimum de pension
de toute façon la première heure
travaillée donnera des droits
et c'est exactement ce que nous avions
indiqué et débattu à plusieurs reprises
voilà pour l'avis défavorable
merci je vais mettre aux voix
ces amendements alors d'abord
l'amendement 25
il a des sous-amendements il a des
sous-amendements celui ci d'abord les
sous-amendement 42 605 qui est pour et
qui est contre rejeté 40 2 604 c'est un
sous-amendement également de monsieur de
monsieur qui est pour et qui est contre
rejeté 40 2 606 de monsieur dharréville
sous-amendement qui et pour qui et
contre rejeté la main le 46 ans 1/2
monsieur de monsieur peu qui est pour et
qui est contre rejeté l'amendement
support le 25 55 de monsieur aviragnet
qui est pour et contre rejeté
nous en venons 16 950 à monsieur le
ministre pendant part je vous entends
pas monsieur mais il demande une
soixante séance de 10 minutes allaient
de droit
la séance est reprise la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
le carrier
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
spéciale monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés depuis
la fin du mois de janvier d'abord en
commission spéciale puis en séance
publique l'assemblée nationale examine
les projets de loi instituant un système
universel de retraite projet de loi
simple et projet de loi organique
après plus de cent quinze heures de
débats en séance publique
de jour comme de nuit week-end inclus
l'assemblée nationale en est arrivé à
l'examen de l'article 8 d'un projet de
loi ordinaire qui en comptent 65 plus de
29 mille 29 1273 si mon compte est bon
amendements restent à examiner
permettez moi de rendre un hommage
appuyé aux membres à tous les membres de
la commission spéciale à sa présidente
au rapporteur général ainsi qu'aux
différents rapporteurs
qui ont fait preuve d'une très grande
persévérance dans l'exercice de leur
mission ils ont tenté de présenter un
texte de le corriger de le compléter
d'éclairer les français sur les enjeux
d'une transformation majeure ce travail
qui a été conduit dans un contexte
parfois tendues a témoigné
d'exceptionnelles qualités de sang froid
et de maîtrise pour assumer leur mission
est tout simplement faire leur travail
beaucoup de députés de la majorité comme
des oppositions ont dû faire face
c'était le début de leurs travaux à une
stratégie d'obstruction délibérée de la
part d'une minorité une stratégie je me
permets de le rappeler puisqu'elle a été
présenté et assumée comme telle qui
avait pour unique finalité d'empêcher la
tenue du débat ou d'interdire le fait
que l'on puisse arriver à son père un
force est donc de constater que la
discussion sur le fond n'a jamais
vraiment pu se lier ou alors de manière
parcellaire et souvent décousu
je le regrette profondément comme vous
tous sur ces banques comme des millions
de français
j'attendais beaucoup de ce débat un
débat que ces oeuvres r&d en ce qui nous
concerne dans un esprit d'ouverture
ce débat aurait dû permettre de
constater nos convergences et nos
désaccords de clarifier nos positions de
confronter nos points de vue devant les
français en respectant les règles c'est
dans les règles de cette assemblée
s'il vous plaît ce débat
ce débat aurait dû nous permettre de
répondre aux questions parfaitement
légitime est très précise que des
oppositions ont soulevé et je dois dire
mesdames et messieurs les députés qu'il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'illustrations aussi
éloquente que ce à quoi nous assistons
en ce moment
le débat aurait dû nous permettent de
répondre aux questions parfaitement
légitime et très précise que des
oppositions ont soulevé des oppositions
qui parce qu'elles ont respecté la
démocratie en choisissant de déposer des
amendements qui porte sur le fond ont
été in fine et privés du débat auquel
elle avait droit
voilà ce à quoi aurait dû ressembler ce
débat rien à voir avec les dizaines de
milliers d'amendements qui pour
l'essentiel n'avait pas d'autre but que
de bloquer l'examen du texte
rien à voir avec les incidents de séance
à répétition orchestré pour donner
l'illusion de l'action et du débat
quand l'effet recherché était la
paralysie je ne m'étendrai pas sur
l'image particulièrement triste que
renvoie de nos institutions
les événements de ces derniers jours
toutes les oppositions sont légitimes
bien sûr toutes les contestations
doivent évidemment s'exprimer mais il me
paraît qu'elles doivent le faire dans le
respect des institutions et des
pratiques du débat républicain
je n'ai pas le sentiment que ce à quoi
nous avons assisté soit ce que les
français favorables ou non au projet de
loi d'ailleurs attendent de leurs
représentants je n'ai pas non plus le
sentiment que notre démocratie puisse se
payer le luxe d'un tel spectacle que
notre pays puisse ont regardé défi qu'il
traverse gaspiller l'énergie de ses
représentants dans un tel exercice
énergie considérable dévoués au bien
public que je veux saluer surtout les
rangs de cette sur tous les bancs de cet
hémicycle
c'est un bien dangereux service bien
dangereux et bien mauvais service que
cette obstruction a pu lui rend c'est la
raison pour laquelle conformément à
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la constitution
de 1958 et après en avoir obtenu
l'autorisation du conseil des ministres
du 29 février
[Applaudissements]
continuez monsieur le premier ministre
tout le monde garde son calme ce qui
sonnerait provocation je disais si vous
persistez la situation sera évoquée
devant le bureau vous avez la parole
monsieur le premier ministre je disais
donc que c'était la raison pour laquelle
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 et après en
avoir obtenu l'autorisation du conseil
des ministres du 29 février
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi et
pour permettre à la suite du processus
législatif de s'engager
nous le savons bien mesdames et
messieurs les députés bien souvent le
recours à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
constitution a été utilisée par des
gouvernements obligé de faire face à
l'hostilité de leur majorité sur un
texte de loi ou sur une ligne politique
c'est arrivé ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
cette majorité dont la diversité est une
chance s'est engagé lors des élections
législatives de 2010 est à créer un
système universel de retraites une des
réformes les plus ambitieuses et les
plus complexes c'est vrai de ces
dernières années je suis pour ma part
fier de cette majorité
fier de sa détermination et de sa
mobilisation sans faille pour tenter de
proposer un débat démocratique à la
hauteur des enjeux
je suis fier qu ensemble depuis juin
2010 sept mois après mois nous ayons mis
en oeuvre le programme de transformation
voulue par le président de la république
des transformations qui parfois
attendait depuis bien trop longtemps
d'être mises en oeuvre à bien des égards
à bien des égards la situation dans
laquelle certains ont voulu nous mettre
aujourd'hui est la preuve que ces
transformations nécessite de
l'abnégation et de la volonté politique
pour respecter le travail du parlement
pour tenir compte aussi de la pluralité
de son expression politique par esprit
de dialogue et de compromis avec les
partenaires sociaux
j'engage la responsabilité du
gouvernement sur un texte qui n'est pas
le texte initial que nous avons déposée
sur le bureau de l'assemblée nationale
c'est un texte c'est un texte mesdames
et messieurs les députés améliorer
profondément enrichis grâce à tous les
amendements que nous intégrons à ce
texte
il traduit tout d'abord les deux
derniers mois de concertation engagée
avec les partenaires sociaux sur les
sujets liés à la pénibilité à l'emploi
des seniors et à la transition
prévention de la pénibilité dans les
branches professionnelles développement
de la retraite progressive et du compte
épargne temps dans les entreprises comme
dans le secteur public
je ne cite là que quelques exemples des
nombreuses avancées issues de la
démocratie sociale et vous le savez les
discussions à
avec et entre les partenaires sociaux
vont se poursuivre sur la pénibilité
dans sa dimension réparation sur le
financement et sur la gouvernance
notamment dans le cadre de la conférence
de financement sur ces sujets le texte
reste donc ouvert je veux le dire
fortement
je fais confiance au dialogue social
j'ai dit aussi à plusieurs reprises que
je saurai prendre mes responsabilités
si cela s'avère nécessaire un texte
améliorée et enrichie aussi évidemment
grâce au travail parlementaire qui
permet de consolider d'autres mesures de
justice sociale pour les personnes
handicapées pour les femmes pour les
jeunes je pense à la consolidation des
pensions de réversion je pense à des
droits familiaux encore plus protecteur
pour les femmes
je pense à la retraite progressive à 55
ans pour les personnes en situation de
handicap
un texte un texte qui évolue enfin pour
traduire l'engagement pris par le
gouvernement de transformer des
habilitations en articles rédigés en dur
comme on dit parfois près de cet article
d'habilitation sont transformés par des
dispositions législatives d'application
directe
j'ose espérer qu'après l'adoption de ce
texte en première lecture le débat
pourra poursuivre son cheminement au
parlement dans un climat apaisé
c'est le sens de la décision que j'ai
prise de recourir aux dispositions qui
figure à l'article 49 3 de la
constitution comme d'ailleurs d'autres
dans des circonstances analogues l'ont
fait avant moi c'est le voeu du
gouvernement et je sais aussi que c'est
le voeu de la très grande majorité
d'entre vous je vous remercie
merci merci monsieur le premier ministre
l'assemblée
l'assemblée nationale pract delà de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement conformément aux
dispositions 49 alinéa 3 de la
constitution
la liste des amendements que le premier
ministre a évoqué est en train d'être
distribuées le texte sur lequel le
premier ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
inséré annexe aux comptes rendus de la
présente séance à d'application de
l'article 55 alinéa 1er du règlement
le débat est immédiatement suspendu ce
texte sera considéré comme adopté sauf
si une motion de censure déposée avant
demain 17h35 et voté dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
constitution
dans l'hypothèse où une motion de
censure serait déposée
la conférence des présidents fixera la
date et les modalités de sa discussion
la séance est levée
[Applaudissements]